the massachusetts uh uh taxation of
their income i earned in this state
that i'm not sure of i'm happy to look
back uh through our records i didn't
check before i came in this morning and
see if we got notice of anyone
challenging it i can certainly supply in
my along with my written testimony the
uh
the answer to that question if we have
one more follow-up sir
[Music]
lacking any specific law
how can a new hampshire resident
rely upon
the general con the
interpretation by the irs that the
taxation only takes place
in the state where the work took place
if there's no law in new hampshire
stating
that it's the state's interest
then the state
can't support
an individual in their private lawsuit
so if a law like this or with certain
maybe a couple of language changes that
dra may recommend
would not then you as a litigator
have a stronger case
in the supreme court maybe you get your
quill
arguing this by saying it's the
law of new hampshire it's the practice
of new hampshire and this law
does nothing more than supplement
what the irs has already said
is their regulation
um
so a couple responses
to that and i do appreciate the question
because i think it's getting a a a
pretty important
point at least in my mind um
the first is i i would have to go turn
back to the irs guidance and see
specifically what it says
my recollection but i i don't want to be
held to this is that it still may leave
open the question about what it
means to perform work within the state
whether having your employer there and
having
your work product transmitted there
having payroll there is sufficient
connection or being physically present
is required and i need to i would need
to go um see whether the irs guidance
speaks to that question um i do think um
and this is getting back to the to the
first question
um from today that if the if the
legislature were to speak on this issue
i think it would certainly um
confirm uh what i think we we tried to
powerfully explain to the supreme court
which is that new hampshire does have a
sovereign interest in this we have no
idea why the supreme court declined to
hear our case either maybe they
disagreed with that maybe a few justices
did
maybe they disagreed that this was you
know sufficiently
meritorious to to warrant uh
review i don't know i hope not i think
our i found arguments compelling and i
hope the justices did too um what i can
say is that even a law like this though
will not um
will not counter or or at least wouldn't
um foreclose a state like massachusetts
from making what its central argument
was um which may have been a persuasive
one uh which is there is a path for
taxpayers individually to challenge this
and they can challenge it all the way up
to the supreme court and in fact the
case is coming out of new york there
were petitions for rid of certiorari
there that the supreme court ultimately
denied and and that was massachusetts
central argument all the time which is
you can come through our system and you
can go to the supreme court and the
state of new hampshire's
role in this isn't essential and the
supreme court shouldn't allow new
hampshire to use its uh
kind of this extraordinary relief
through a petition for original
jurisdiction directly in the supreme
court um i don't know whether that
argument persuaded the justices i do
know that that was really the main
argument that massachusetts made to
counter our petition and um and while a
law like this may bolster us in the
future saying
new hampshire does have an interest it's
an independent interest from its
taxpayers it is an essential sovereign
interest um i suspect the argument we
get in response is the exact same one we
we received this time
thank you mr chair um
i would like to the chair to ask if we
can get the
either the irs guidance itself or an
analysis of it uh as the uh as mr uh
garland does his work
we will try thank you sir
next is representative alame followed by
representative jaquesian and then i'd
like to have the dre
respond
representative thank you uh
have you talked with the other states
that few states that do not have an
income tax
to see if we could possibly get them to
join in the next time and
uh would that help to get scotus to do
it
so before um
or while we were preparing uh the
petition this time i i can't remember
the specific timing but there is a
process
under which you seek amicus support for
your position um it goes through the
national association of attorneys
general which i believe almost every
state is a member of
we got i think
i want to say maybe 13 states that came
in to support us one way or the other um
a handful of states that have been
affected by policies uh like the one we
were challenging so new jersey in
particular came in on that position i
believe connecticut did too because it
has an interest with how new york is
taxing um we got a handful of states
that came in uh taking a position that
they often do which is that the us
supreme court's original jurisdiction is
mandatory it doesn't have the discretion
to to decline to hear a case we
obviously weren't persuasive in that
regard um at least this time around um i
i can't recall whether other states came
in without income taxes i do remember
part of the analysis that
that we we did back at the time when we
were bringing this lawsuit is that new
hampshire is awfully unique
with respect to the uh the volume of
workers from southern new hampshire that
do work in massachusetts and that many
of the other income tax states may not
have had that geographic um similarity
and so i can double check to see whether
any of the amica support was from states
without income taxes but we certainly
did reach out to every state every other
state in the country and did get a fair
amount of support for our position
it's power
isn't montana one of the
income no income tax states i'm trying
to remember
but uh
i know uh let me see it's oregon no it's
what
washington that depends on the i can
never remember which of them does anyway
uh
with the remote
access growing and a lot of
forest fires and other problems out
there
i should imagine that there are
uh
there is a growing number of people in
those states also that
that
are working remotely with a place that
is an income tax state
i shouldn't
try and talk to them directly
so i i can never i get the
income and sales tax states confused and
so i can never off the top of my head
remember which are which either um
i i i i would i should say so i i think
one one of the arguments we certainly
put into one of our filings that may
have been our reply brief um
was that
this trend to toward remote work like i
said before isn't going to change it's
going to we we anticipate it's going to
continue in that direction going forward
and at that point which again was you
know the better part of a year ago um
we were
we had uh you know examples of major
companies saying they may remain remote
work companies going forward or at least
keep policies in place where more
employees could
work remotely
and so i do believe that this is an
issue
that isn't going to go away i think the
issue has changed with respect to new
hampshire at least in the short term
it's an issue that i do hope the supreme
court takes it's really a question of
the vehicle and also a question i think
of i've been sharing that new hampshire
taxpayers
don't believe that they have a
protection that maybe the supreme court
says they don't i mean we would
vigorously argue that our
our position was correct and it should
be the the law of the land but um as we
know from prior experience that hasn't
always worked and so uh and so that's
the risk that i that i see in this
legislation
representative
followed by repton and schamberg
and
aaron
thank you mr chairman thank you for
coming in absolutely and talking to us
um
so
it's it it sounds like and there's a
great probability that this could come
back up again
um i mean i
am very strong in the
thought process that we want to be
proactive
i personally don't want to wait until
the next thing happens and then we have
to scramble to do something i think
the time to protect new hampshire
residents is now
and so
i guess my question to you would be you
know maybe this isn't the perfect
language
do you have a suggestion
on how we could
tighten it up and make it potentially
better in case you do have to go to the
supreme court again
um yeah i guess i'll start with that um
so that was something that was actually
a question i anticipated um i i
received notice of this bill uh last
week i know it's been pending for for um
a month now um and so we haven't had a
time chance internally to have the
conversation of what that language might
may look like but i'm certainly
more than happy to go back to the doj
and i think we would be willing
participants in trying to craft language
um that has the effect that that
addresses the concern that that you're
identifying which is if this issue comes
up again kind of bolstering the state's
position if and when we go to the
supreme court in a way that may
alleviate some of the concerns i've
expressed today so if that's um
something that the committee would would
like us to look into i'm happy to bring
that back and i believe having spoken
with the attorney general there's
enthusiasm on our part to play a role in
that
okay great thank you
we certainly would be happy to have you
do that
representative schambard
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
absolutely
i will have two questions so i'll have a
follow-up mr chairman
could you tell us what the convenience
of employer doctrine is
i can try my best to explain it bill
artinger would be the right person to
explain that in detail um
as i understand that the the the name is
actually a bit of a misnomer it's the
idea that if uh if an employee is
working remotely in a different state um
as a matter of convenience as rather
than as a matter of necessity um at
least as far as new york is concerned
that new york can continue to tax um
that the income of that employee and so
if someone's working in new jersey
because
uh
because the company thinks it's better
for them to be there or the or the
person desires to not have to commute
into new york city that that would
really i think be on the side of the
convenience of the employer doctor and
whereas if you if you have to work from
home um maybe due to an accommodation
for a disability um other circumstances
that may be on the other side of it so
um i'm certainly willing to try to find
a better explanation than that but
that's really where the convenience
comes in it's really not a matter of
necessity that sounded good follow-up
follow-up the the second part of this is
when an employee does an employee have a
contract formed in massachusetts
when they sign on with a company in
massachusetts and must they follow that
contract which might say you will pay
your
taxes
that are required to massachusetts
i i suspect that the the uh
the employment relationship may vary on
whether someone's a contract employee
whether someone's an at will employee
and really what the terms of the
agreement look like
i do think an argument
we didn't see the argument but i could
anticipate an argument being made that
if you form a contract in massachusetts
to work for a massachusetts company
that's a sufficient connection with the
state to be subject to that state's
taxes i haven't seen that specific
argument but i could foresee that coming
up
what i can say is that the businesses
that that we um
spoke to about this issue in the context
of the supreme court um appeal they
didn't
at least to us weren't taking one side
or the other it was really just a
question of of uh making sure it was
administratively feasible to to do this
so they didn't want a situation where a
bunch of employees were subject to
certain rules that that other people
weren't and you can understand that from
a business perspective that it's
different from the legal perspective of
course thank you very much
and representative aaron
yes thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
representative schomburg pretty much
asked my question because i i know
people who
uh
work remotely
for companies that are in
another state
and but their status is of co as is that
they are contractors as opposed to
some other status of employee
and i was just wondering you know how
that
how that would uh you know make a
difference
in in terms of the law and this law
uh i think employee status can make a
significant difference it's going to be
one of um
one of my frustrating answers i think
that it is really going to depend on the
terms of the employment and the state's
law that um that is that is seeking to
tax you i mean the challenge we have
with taxation laws is that you have a
federal jurisdiction you have you know
51-ish state jurisdictions plus you have
a whole bunch of different local
jurisdictions and so you know i think
when we were working on it in the
wayfarer context we're seeing upwards of
10 000 different
potential taxing authorities it may be
different in the context of income
but the laws can vary from place to
place and it's very hard to
if not you know certainly beyond maybe
my skill level to understand
specifically on a granular level what
every taxing authority is doing but i
think you're hitting on a pretty vital
point which is not only is this a
complicated question of constitutional
law a position that a question that we
think we have a very good argument under
but in terms of how it affects
individual new hampshire residents or
individual employees it is going to be a
question that turns on where they're
working in the terms of their in their
terms of their uh relationship with the
employer where that employer um
where that employer resides and so it is
a
as with all things taxation there is no
clear answer let me put it that way
thank you
representative nunes
thank you mr chairman thank you for
being here for us today and and this is
kind of a comment kind of a question i i
don't know where it's exactly where it's
going to go i'm one of those people
that for 25 years i worked in another
state i air commuted back and forth
there were times when we
questioned whether or not we were going
to be taxed in another state
and uh we got a clarification now this
is several years ago and i don't know if
this is still in tax code for the irs
now but we were given clarification from
our employer that if we spent more than
50 percent of our working time in that
state then we would be taxed in that
state
but if the contract was considered that
we would work remote whenever
was agreed upon by the the client and
the employ our employer
then we would not be taxed for working
in that state and there were many there
are many uh instances where
we
we worked only remote and we were never
taxed in that state and that's when when
these instances came up in new york and
massachusetts i tried to pay attention
i've been retired for several years now
so i'm not up on the irs codes but i did
implement payroll systems in 40 states
so uh i'm very interested in where this
is going to go
and
i i think that i think it was
representative ames that said we may
want to look at the irs tax code what
the current code is now because that may
give a reflection as to what the rest of
the states are doing and how they're how
they're behaving towards this i was a
little shocked when massachusetts came
up with this i know why they did but um
but uh you know because of all the
crossover into their state it was a very
controversial move so if you can talk to
that any at all i don't know if you need
to
i can make a couple of brief comments
and respect in response to that um the
the first uh thing that you hit on was
this idea of of more than 50 percent of
time um within estate subject attacks um
and as i understand it that's one of
at least three different ways states
have gone about doing this
whether you spend the majority of the
time there or the on the flip side kind
of a convenience of the employer that's
where your employer lives and so or
where your employer resides and so it
doesn't really matter where you're doing
work and then massachusetts's rule the
rule that was in effect before the
emergency rule and as i understand it
the rule that's gone back into effect is
effect as effectively a um a days in
days out sort of um rule so that if if
you're working three of your five days
within massachusetts your subject income
tax on those three days and so really
it's a physical presence when you're
there um and what other states are doing
i really can't speak to that right now
but i do suspect you're going to find at
least those three examples and and maybe
upwards of you know
many more i don't even want to put a
number on it um
and it is where that's where it gets
awfully complicated i think it in
particular for you know for businesses
that are trying to um
to make payroll decisions that because
it could vary very much based on where
their employers are and and uh we've
certainly heard that in the sales tax
context and that's really what we were
hearing from businesses in the context
of this issue too that they they wanted
just have an answer to the question it
was really that from a business
standpoint that seemed to be the greater
interest than any particular legal
position but it does add another layer
of complication to the issue
representation yearly has a follow up
yeah to add another layer
as you put it
football players when they travel from
state to state
particularly california new york and
massachusetts are subject to paying that
state's tax
for an afternoon's work
that's not anywhere near the 50 percent
of their work time
it's a temporary job and yet they're
still paying a state sales tax so i i
think that's an area that needs
to be
added to this
rule that we're looking at thank you sir
thank you uh for bringing that up uh
representing newman
okay i'm going to have
ken
representing
just a quick follow-up it's sounding
like
if on
a town
on one side of a county in colorado
decides to tax this a different way than
the rest of colorado
that also gets entered into the equation
we i remember we were talking about the
extreme difficulty of figuring things
out in colorado
on the sales tax one
the one thing i don't know the answer to
um
with respect to that question is whether
um the extent to which localities may
have separate income tax rules uh in the
way that they do sales tax rules i i
simply don't know um we focused it on it
from a state level of course um
i do believe at least there are some
large cities that have separate income
taxes but i'm actually not a 100 sure of
that but yes to the extent there are
localities that are that are
adding an additional layer of potential
taxation here that that does make the
question more complicated
representative murphy uh thank you mr
chairman and thank you for your uh
testimony uh just to follow up to uh
representative zanigan's concept of a
pre-emptive strike having a
legislative um
law in place to
argue for the supreme court in general
does the supreme court or anybody
involved in tax law
have a hierarchy of authority meaning
does the federal versus a state versus
the local tax
laws
preempt other ones or have authority of
the other in general
that's a good question and so from a
specific tax concept um i i don't know
the answer and i'm certainly happy to
try to find it what i can say though is
um generally speaking federal law um
under the supremacy clause preempts
state law and as a there's a version of
state supremacy over local law as well
that's i understand a little more
complicated
what i can also say is as far as the us
supreme court is concerned um
it usually isn't taking up cases dealing
with individual taxpayers and resolving
tax conflicts what it's much more
concerned about is questions of you know
significant open questions of
constitutional law and the open
questions here are significant it's it's
whether a state can even do this um
under the due process clause of the 14th
amendment and under the commerce clause
um
and that's the sort of question that we
presented to the u.s supreme court um i
think it would be much harder to
convince the supreme court to take a
case that was really based on an
interpretation of just new hampshire law
that those are not the sorts of cases
that that the court is typically taking
and in some instances their cases the
supreme court said it won't resolve that
basically that's left to the state
system
okay
i'd like to hear from the dra
kim
juan
good morning representatives my name is
king mingwong tax policy counselor from
the department of revenue administration
um the department does not have a
position uh is not taking a position on
this bill at this current time
as as you know
there is no personal income tax
in new hampshire
but the department is concerned with the
language as it currently stands on the
um on the proposed bill
the
uh are you going to point out though
um so one of the items would be the the
statement to say that no no state has
the power so that's on line five
of the bill uh no state has the power to
tax earned income sorry tax value earned
outside of its borders
um
so that harkens back to the uh the
interpretation from the supreme court in
terms of the due process and the
commerce clause um the federal
of the u.s constitution
um but in addition to that as some of
the representatives have mentioned here
uh it also
um this is not the the um the complete
um ruling uh it also interferes with the
um
with the with the
application towards business taxation as
administered
by
in new hampshire
especially
specifically for business taxes
where
we would
there is this concept of unitary
unitary business
in um
combined reporting
so where
there is this concept of the transfer of
value so a value could be earned in one
state but there's also a transfer of ex
or exchange in value between states
where uh one business organization may
be conducting business activities in
more than one state
so
this this ve we we feel that this
current language of
not having the power to tax value earned
outside of its borders
if this value is transferred to another
state so let's say transferred to new
hampshire or from new hampshire transfer
to another state so the the concept of
unitary
businesses which is
currently recognized
by the supreme court uh might be
challenged might be might be maybe a
challenging concept for us to
to continue to administer the um
the apportionment of income to to new
hampshire
um
so
those are one of the uh the concerns
that we would have uh with this current
language and the dra
is
is willing to work with with the
representatives and with the attorney
general's office in terms of trying to
if this bill were to to proceed we would
definitely want to be involved and try
to help to
provide our
input into this
this bill
thank you for your testimony questions
from the committee
representative
thank you mr chair uh
kane could
could you uh work out
uh
some specifics on each of the ones that
you think
could distort the way we do our taxes
now
and give us
an example or a couple of examples
of hypotheticals
of how it would have to change
sure yeah we can work on that thank you
any further questions uh representative
jeanine
thank you mr chairman this is more just
a
a comment um i'm pleased to hear that
that you would work with the
attorney general's office to craft
something that makes sense i think
um
the
immediacy of this while there's no
immediacy right this second we don't
know when it could come up i think again
being proactive is
is good and um
i appreciate that okay
representative romney there's a question
for the chair for a comment
it appears that we're at a crossroads
here in terms of
of do we first off do we do we want to
fix this
so that it would
at least hold some water to defend
against
any possible attack from from other
states
thus maybe going to the supreme court
again so i think i think i think we
should have two votes on this a straw
poll maybe not maybe now but maybe we
meet next week
as before we we asked the ag and the
department of revenue to work on this i
think we want to have a sense if the
committee wants that to happen first
so that we know they don't waste their
time that's all that's my comment on it
but i i probably would support them
working on it but uh but i think the the
committee should weigh in if they if
that's what we want if no sense in
having them do the work
and then us voting no
although there may be some value mr
chair because
uh as they go through because and these
things when it goes when it comes to
this kind of thing as we learned when we
were working on wayfair
every word counts every word counts
and uh hopefully we can craft something
that you know will
hold the weight
of a potential challenge thank you
representative spellsbury
thank you mr chairman
yeah i think
the idea of a straw poll to determine
which direction we even want to go
would be very helpful today
so for example
i don't think that we're
constructively in the zone of tweaking
this language
uh an example would be
if uh keane has suggested that value
earned is maybe too vague a term to work
with
you could literally drop the phrase
value earned outside of its borders
therefore
so that it just goes straightforwardly
no state has the power to tax income
earned
you could even interject the word
personally earned to distinguish it from
business tags
you could do these things
the problem though is
that's
sorting out the words
of this particular
draft
doesn't get us where we want to go
because this draft
essentially is declaring to another
state
you can't tax our residents
and we have no power
to back that up and enforce it
so the real question going back to our
discussion with mr garland
is
from the ag's perspective
is there anything that we could do
instead of being directed to the bad boy
other state
is there something we could do that's
directed to the united states supreme
court
or directed to the attorney general
that sets the stage
for them to be successful if this rears
its head again
and
i'm not sure
that there is anything we could say that
would influence the supreme court
but but if if there's even a chance of
that it's probably simply
a statement
that it is the sovereign interest and
the tax policy of the state of new
hampshire
not to tax
its
residents
on income personally earned
and therefore
that any tax any any action taken by
other state
that would
assert attacks over its residents
undermines the tax policy of the state
of new hampshire
and therefore
gives standing to the state
for the attorney general to assert its
claims
now
frankly i don't know whether that would
actually mean anything to the supreme
court but it's the only thing i can see
can conceive of that would make it worth
having a bill
that would raise a lot of other
different questions
and
issues
it just
further complicates the whole thing oh
yeah
so
represent ames
i'm glad we have a number of lawyers
here
and probably for every lawyer who wants
to speak on this issue you get a
different opinion
and none of us know what the supreme
court will do
and i
welcome representative spillsbury's
comment i
my own view is that
there needs to be something that is as
significant in the sense of a
controversy
for the supreme court to take up an
issue
uh there's got to be something that's
that's got to be resolved and as an
assertion by the state
just a an assertion
without more without a context like that
i don't think we'll
we'll gain the attention of a supreme
court that's already too busy and we
shouldn't waste our time in that beyond
that i think a lot of work needs to be
done
to identify the discrete issue
that
we're concerned about that doesn't
uh interfere with our tax policy that's
been in place for a very long time
particularly with the business taxes
so that's my comment
it almost seems like if we want to go
forward with anything on this bill
we have a lot of work to do
and
be a candidate for interim study if we
want to do that
representative yearly
i think your analysis on that is correct
but
i but following up on what uh attorney
garland had suggested
there and it's the same article the same
problem we had with wayfair
we need to get a definitive answer the
entity giving the definitive answer is
going to be scotus
needs to be a mechanism
to get to scotus
and just like
the commerce clause came into existence
between new york taxi new jersey
then
we need to do that can you identify that
i think this is a vehicle i thought
wayfarer was a vehicle too but we kind
of sidestepped that
um
but
interim study
but let's uh
come up with some language to go in to
study with and ask the two agencies to
come up with language that protects our
interests as well
but
to get something that triggers original
jurisdiction
should be the goal i would think and i
think that should be the direction to
both of the agencies
comments from others
rather than aaron
thank you
while i
appreciate the notion of interim study i
would be against that
simply because i think that we need to
craft something now
to protect the
workers in our state
and
my thought is i'm not a lawyer
but i know that people who are working
remotely are not using the
infrastructure
that their tax
would pay for
they're not traveling into this other
state
they're not using any of the
amenities of the other state
and on top of that
there's taxation without representation
they have no say in how their money is
being used
and i think those are constitutional
issues
so
it's important i think to protect
the the money that these people are
making uh for the work that they're
doing whether
you know that they're doing at their
home or
away from
their the other state
and i just think the sooner that we do
something
in new hampshire to protect these
employees the better
any further comments uh representative
elmi
thank you uh
if on
if that company did not exist in the
other state that person would not have a
job
at least not in that state
i
i think that
interim study is really the way to go
and to leave it to the ag's office and
the dra
to try to maneuver the shoals of this
and see if there's something we can do
to
shore up
a future challenge if it comes and i'm
pretty sure it's not going to come this
in during the next year
any further comments and representation
followed by representative nunes thank
you mr chairman i i
i understand the sentiment for interim
study um but i would be against interim
study
um i think we're just pushing it off
um i i think
that working
letting the ag's office and dra work on
some language
that
would help in a potential future supreme
court case
i think is is advisable in my opinion i
think we need to go that route because
putting it off i think the the truth of
the matter is we're not going to
do that much with it we're not going to
do enough work to make sure that
um
we are prepared we don't know when this
is going to happen we can lull ourselves
to sleep and think that you know
nothing's going to happen for another
year or whenever but i'm i feel like we
want to be prepared
um
working on this i think makes sense
and so i would um i would push that we
we have dra and the attorney general's
office craft some language that could
work i mean on the on the flip side of
this i don't know how good a comparison
this is but
new massachusetts residents who come up
to new hampshire and work at a new
hampshire company
we all know massachusetts says okay
pay the complete tax owed to us that
massachusetts is charging the complete
tax they have laws that require that
their residents who work in new
hampshire or any other state that
doesn't have a tax pay the tax i don't
see why
the reverse of that where you're a new
hampshire resident you're working in new
hampshire okay you work for a mass
company fine but we're gonna
make the assertions that this bill
proposes and certainly i agree that the
language could be tightened up
representative ames makes a good point
we don't want to inadvertently create a
situation where it's affecting
our business tax collections um and the
um
the prorations based on what state
that's earned in so
um i with that i think we should um we
should continue working on this and
i'd like to see an amendment uh proposed
on this
thank you okay
representative yearly
uh i'm sorry represent noon is first
annually
thank you mr chairman
um we've identified a few gray areas in
this bill in our discussion here today
and particularly uh the attorney
general's office in dra who have been
very kind to let us know their thoughts
we did uncover in our discussions with
you things that needed to be looked at i
think that we actually need to look at
the irs code and find out what the irs
code says and that may give us some
standing as to where we could move
forward
and particularly
while there is not an issue right now
there is a historical issue because it
just happened
through the emergency order from
massachusetts our residents got taxed on
their payroll and even though that went
away it still happened so we do have a
standing issue
it's just not currently in effect so
i think that i think that because of
those gray areas we deserve to look at
this just a little bit more before we
make a determination whether or not this
goes into is
thank you mr chairman
representing you early i thank you mr
chair that was a good summation i would
request the chair
in this uh discussion
we have a little horse in the selectmen
bureau and when we beat it enough we
knock it over
but i would also urge the agencies to
understand that new hampshire has often
been
a
precedent center at the supreme court on
a variety of different things and this
could be one that would deal with both
the 10th amendment and
the interstate commerce clause regarding
taxation across state borders and
clarifying those
the
per umbra of
tax laws that kind of etch into
the residents of both of all states
uh through the tax code so thank you for
this and thank you for setting up the
meetings coming forward
we've had a lot of discussion on this
bill
and
different opinions
and we're going to continue this at a
work session next thursday and we'll
make a decision at that point in time in
the meantime
if the attorney general and the dra
would provide
information that
they've been asked to provide that would
be very helpful to us
and if you could provide that
information prior to the meeting so that
we have time to go over it that would be
even more helpful
so i'm going to close the work session
on house bill
1097.
the next
work session is on house bill 1221-fn
relative to the rate of the business
profits tax in the business enterprise
tax
and what information does the committee
need
or questions that they have
represent
mr chair i don't i don't understand how
dri came up with their fiscal note of
indeterminable if they use a static
analysis they can give us a static
figure granted they cannot give us an
active figure based upon
potential stimulation of
business but they could
correlate
what happened when we reduced it the
last time
as to what an additional reduction would
take place
and that might be interesting to see
representative brian uh just respond to
that uh i think there is they give us a
static analysis on the second and third
page of the fiscal note
it's quite extensive
okay
yeah yeah they make some assumptions and
then
give us a sense of the amounts
they break it down to bppt and but they
didn't yeah but what they didn't talk
about is what the relationship was i
didn't see or didn't i don't understand
the relationship couldn't possibly be
the latter uh between what happened when
we reduced it the last time and we had a
growth of in revenue when it was
projected to be a decrease in revenue
i
confused
uh representation
thank you uh
i just want to respond to that we have
to remember our taxes lag by three years
we have to remember we've made all kinds
of other changes in our taxes we have to
remember that the general economy of the
nation and the huge stimulus payments
and other things that have affected our
taxes over the years
factor in strongly to what the actual
revenues come out as i've been trying to
work with chris shea on
looking at
the
presumed impact even of the tax cuts
starting in 15
all the way through
and he's having enormous difficulty
doing that because of all of the
different things that have changed
sometimes multiple changes in rates
taking things back putting things in
uh
that
got factored into the new fiscal notes
as they did it in a new environment for
the next round
robin early what's the hourly rate to
rent uh time at one watson
the ibm super computer that
forget it
we could probably get a remy and they
would give us a a number that we would
all disagree with
okay i think this is one
that
some of you will say
we need
and then there's
others that say
let's wait until
we see
uh the result of all the other tax cuts
that are
in play now
and
i don't represent
lying
thank you mr chair well i love this bill
i i am concerned about i'm going to use
the the term fake money all the stimulus
money that's been dumped into the
economy that we actually have no impact
on how our economy is going to settle
out when we're all done
i mean when we add more variables into
that when we look at the pre the tax
cuts we've done in hb2
um just this last year and how that's
going to settle out as well
i i do think again i hate as a
republican to say this i do think that
um this is ill-advised at this time that
we we probably should hold off and see
how things set up my biggest concern is
the stimulus like i call fake money all
the money that got dumped into the
economy
that ultimately we're going to pay in
taxes or some somewhere else
but we don't know what the real impact
of all that money was in the state and
how that's going to inflate impact our
businesses when next year that money's
not around and we don't have it and and
so
at best i'd be an interim study on this
bill um because i think that again we
just don't know the long-term impact of
what you know the last two years of
dumping fake money into the economy is
going to have on the new hampshire
economy
thank you representative lang and
that mirrors
my concern too
because
we have all this extra money
the surplus statement says that we have
like 275 million dollars excess
money
for this last fiscal year
but it really is not
there as excess
because we have some liabilities against
that
we changed our ppp
taxes
uh and that came about as house bill 2
so that
according to the dra they probably
collected about 100 million dollars that
has to be paid back
we
have all these
ppp uh we have all these stimulus
packages as representative lang says
they haven't settled down and
and how much of the excess revenues that
we have
is associated with that
credit carryovers that have exploded
they went from the
low 100s to close to 300 million dollars
if you just take the credit carry over
and the ppp
that would throw us almost 100 million
dollars in deficit rather than 275
million so i i agree that we have to be
very careful on this and
personally i would say this one needs to
go to independent interim study
representative me
thank you i would just like to add to
that
that on we have radically changed our
business tax the business profits tax
which is our most important tax at state
level
and
on we have absolutely no idea what
that's going to do
it was producing
uh we did dra did analyses on i think it
was
16 and 17 or
uh the revenues from 16 and 17.
and
they
maybe the two years before that as well
what would have happened if we'd used
sales only
to as the allocation for uh
business the business profits tax
on
and we were we were doing a little
better a little worse a little worse
by average but we were only talking
about a couple of million and then in
2018 numbers when they did that last
year it was 72 million we would have
lost
we have no idea
whether that would continue
at this point
if it did we would already have made a
major a massive tax cut mostly for
manufacturers and mostly for the largest
companies
in the state
and quite a few of them are going to end
up with no tax
and the idea is that we would get it
back from
manufacturers and others that are
selling into our state but we don't
consume as much as other states we're
old
so
and we export things
to other states before they go to retail
so that doesn't count
i'm all set i just wanted to point out
that we have made a massive change
to that and we have no idea what it's
going to look like and we'll start to
find out next year
thank you
okay so on house bill 1221 anybody else
representative
thank you mr chairman i'll
echo my sentiment from last time i think
the bill as a whole i i agree with you
and others who are concerned that we
don't know the full impact of all the
tax cuts we've made so
this this bill has presented um it would
be it would be tough to go along with
this not knowing what that revenue is
however i'll propose what i said last
time i i would
i'm really struggling with the idea of
potentially having an amendment here
that looks at the bpt only that lowers
the bpt from 7.6 to 7.5
doesn't touch the bet leaves it as is
in that regard based on these estimates
we're looking at eight million dollar
reduction in revenue to the state
however
i i firmly believe that when
businesses are looking to come to this
state
or compare with other states the bpt is
the top line tax they're looking at
they're not looking at bet
many of them may not even be aware of it
but bpt
is highly visible and i think one to 7.5
makes sense it would require an
amendment here that
obviously changes his bill to just the
7.5 bpt so
um
that would be my
position i would like to bring an
amendment that does that
unless no one else agrees with it then
okay i don't want to waste any other
comments
then
bring your amendment in the next
all week
and we will discuss it
i just want to make an apology
romney yeah thank you mr chair i i
apologize people i i i'm
always
very courteous but i i i'm in my phone
for one reason
as i'm on standby for a bill over in
legislative hall
they're telling me how many pink cards
left in the bill before
so i apologize to everybody that i'm
doing this but i have no choice
i want to hear this but i'm also on
standby when that other hearing is done
before my bill's hearing i'm introducing
the bill thank you
okay we're going to go to house bill
i'm gonna skip to that because
there's two people that have come in
and there's a time constraint
15 24. mr chairman yes
thank you very much for moving them
ahead they're on a
tight schedule i appreciate that
let me
uh it's gretchen stallings and
aaron
johnson
andrea johnson
from new hampshire from volunteer new
hampshire
okay house bill
1524-fn is an act establishing a
national service alumni attraction and
retention fund
and
we have gretchen stalin and andrew
johnson right
andrea andre
hello okay
um first i want to thank you uh for your
service and for inviting us to come in
and share today
um
so
i'm not sure how acquainted you all are
with volunteer new hampshire but
um
volunteer new hampshire envisions our
state as a place where citizens
volunteers like all of you come together
to build strong and connected
communities
we bring our vision together by engaging
individuals in service to their local
communities to address the challenges
through volunteerism
our primary goals are really to connect
volunteers
with opportunities to provide service
we celebrate outstanding volunteer
contributions shining a light on service
so that others may
be aware of opportunities to engage to
make their communities a better place
we provide training to volunteers
volunteer managers and volunteer
champions to partner in addressing
community needs
we steward americorps resources to
tackle new hampshire's most pressing
challenges
i've invited andrea to join me today as
andrea is the americorps program manager
at volunteer new hampshire
additionally volunteer new hampshire we
were established in july of 2001 by
house bill 385
we are a 501 c 3 nonprofit and we are an
appendage to the state department of
administrative services
um we serve as one of 52
state service commissions across the
country so for new hampshire we receive
the national service funds that come
from the federal agency americorps to be
distributed to make americorps grants
and programs within our communities
our primary source of funding is those
funds
last year for example 97 percent of our
funds came directly from americorps
we don't receive state funding
but we do we are a an administrative
attachment to or we are an appendage to
the administrative services so we live
in the dollop building we have a small
staff of five that manages all of the
americorps programs
um with that i'd like to to
offer you some materials that i thought
might just
be helpful for you either now or later
you can look at them while andrea speaks
this first page is uh the portfolio of
americorps programs
that we currently have this year
i've also just included a brochure
that outlines the programming of
volunteer new hampshire and if you're
looking for additional volunteer service
outside of your
your day job and your important
legislative commitment we're happy to
help you with that so
take a look there and then the last
piece we just put together to help
um really to
adhere to your work at hand to try to
answer some questions and give you some
basics so hopefully this will be helpful
um and
with that i'm going to ask andrea just
to speak for a few minutes about the
americorps programs
yes good morning everyone thanks for
having us um so
americorps in new hampshire so
americorps connects individuals and
organizations to solve our community's
toughest
challenges and problems
so there are a lot of benefits to people
serving in americorps first and foremost
is the
professional
development that they get as well as
personal development
they get first-hand experience serving
communities with leadership skills
addressing those community issues
and along with that they do receive a
living allowance which is a very small
sort of stipend that they get for
serving
they also do receive health care and
child care services if they do need that
for serving full time
and then one of the most important
benefits that they get from serving as
well is the sagal education award
so that is used to pay off existing
student loans if they have them but it
can also be used to pay off future
schooling so
not just college but also vocational
schooling
as well so
um serving as an americorps member you
also get exposure to a network of
hundreds of thousands of alumni across
the state
and excuse me across the country
and in new hampshire
we have a portfolio of seven
full-time programs
and within those programs there are
approximately 270
positions that are supported with
federal americorps dollars
those dollars are also matched by the
organizations that have those programs
so it's a perfect example of
public and private partnerships
these programs that we have in this
state
they the members serve at over 40 sites
all across the state
and the focuses on these programs range
from education to
environmental stewardship to assisting
victims of domestic and sexual violence
some examples of programs are you might
all be familiar with the red jackets
down in manchester city or new hampshire
they serve directly in elementary and
secondary schools
and right in manchester
and
they work to improve student scores in
math and reading and they also work on a
social emotional piece as well with
students
we have our student conservation
association that directly partners with
new hampshire state parks
they're based out at bear brook state
park and they're working to keep our
state parks up and running which is
vital to
the
tourism
economy in
new hampshire
and they're out there doing the trail
maintenance and also working on
historical sites as well
and then we have one
our americorps victims assistance
program
they are directly assisting victims of
domestic and sexual violence they serve
at crisis centers around the state and
they also work directly with our police
departments we have a good example of
that in our manchester police department
we have members that serve as part of
their victims assistance unit so they're
helping folks
that need to go through a court process
or
get restraining orders so
really vital and important positions
that those members have
so how is this all connected to
workforce development
well these members are trained to be
strong leaders and
they work with diverse teams they work
individually
they get a ton of on-the-job training
which is so vital to
um folks that are unemployed especially
um youth in their development as well
um a good example of workforce
development with one of our programs is
the
manchester excels program also known as
teach for impact they
have a partnership with southern new
hampshire university where those
members are trained and educated in
secondary education it's a clinical
experience that they work with
manchester schools and
at the end of that they get a
teaching certificate that's a master's
level and it's a pipeline right into the
manchester school district to help with
addressing the critical shortage of
teachers especially as it relates to
stem
so this is a tremendous opportunity
having all of these trained
professional young adults
that can enter the workforce and that
also um you know do want to further
their educational skills and they get
that segal education award so
they have a connection to over 250 000
members that are serving each year
across the country there's also over
seven thousand peace corps members that
serve each year
they're all part of a network of alumni
so
for businesses this is the perfect
opportunity to uh you know reach into
that talent pipeline of trained
individuals and then also for schools
they have all of these members that have
these education awards to use and
they're motivated and they're community
leaders and they want to go to school so
this will help enrollment for all
colleges and universities and then
vocational programs as well
both employers and then these schools
would have access to hundreds of
thousands of americorps alum across the
country
and um
yeah that's
pretty much it anything else to add
gretchen that i might have missed
okay
are you all set now i would just add um
that representative matt wilhelm is also
in the space and he serves on the board
of directors and is also an americorps
alum and
um
if if it would be okay uh mr chair i'd
like to ask if he has anything that he'd
like to
to share
um
why don't we ask if there's questions
from the committee oh sure the two of
you first
questions from the committee
of representative
thank you you talk about
the three-year investment in arpa funds
and what might result from that
uh i think one of the things that we're
after and maybe the representative has
has the information now but
how much uncommitted money is left in
the arpa funds that could be used for
this fund if it was started
would it be okay if i defer to
representative wilhelm for that
okay yes
thank you mr chairman can i get a
clarification uh from
from the two of you um you you talked
about the students and that this would
be tied to the social emotional learning
programs
or did i miss miss here
yes that that i was referring to our
city year americorps program
and those members not only work on
traditional school work but also help
with social emotional through
mentoring the youth and after school
programming and also during during the
school day they help them get to school
they check in with them they work with
them in small groups things like that
questions ask
representative scheinberg thank you mr
chairman i'll ask the question
the the
establishment of this
attraction fund retention fund
why
is it needed
for the state
why do we need this fund
since we have other organ
programs going on what will this fund do
so this fund is specifically to attract
and retain alumni members um and to to
bring back uh or to to keep folks who've
served in americorps and i believe peace
corps and other national service
programs to keep them engaged in
employment and
education opportunities in new hampshire
representative aaron
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
as a follow-up to representative
schoenberg's question
how do they do that
now so right now they received the
siegel education award um and they can
take that and use it at any university
or
institution of higher education across
the country so right now we are seeing a
lot of loss of
folks that are coming in and serving and
then leaving
so i can ask andrea if you want to
elaborate on that
yeah i mean it's this is really to help
in not only to attract and retain um you
know these individuals to stay in new
hampshire and go to college here and
invest in our
education system
but also to be part of our workforce um
you know a lot of folks are coming from
out of state so why not give incentives
to try to keep them here through
bonuses through employers or
you know matching through education
awards
to have them go to school here
i would just add um the data that we uh
we're looking at yesterday that is
looking at the 2000 uh 2021 year um
out of a hundred thousand dollars that
were spent on ed awards that were given
to new hampshire
americorps members only 4 500 were
invested in new hampshire schools all of
the rest was utilized out of state and
so the idea is that if we were to be
able to offer some small match to those
at awards that it would incentivize not
only new hampshire
alumni in using them using their awards
here in new hampshire but it would also
draw folks from across the country to
our institutions of higher education
so follow up and
how do you envision then
if money is put into this fund how does
access happen to that fund
so it would be accessed as matched to
those siegel education awards to
institutions of higher education in new
hampshire and so there's a already an
existing program
new hampshire schools of national
service
where
where schools in new hampshire can offer
to
some some match to that education award
um it could be a partial match to a full
match but just an additional incentive
to draw national service alumni to their
schools and so this would augment that
and then
you know pose as as further incentive to
keep
folks here
in new hampshire to
pursue their education and also to draw
folks from across the country thank you
one further
thank you mr chair
and what typically how much are those
awards
for an individual
yeah so if an individual finishes a
full-time service which is approximately
10 to 12 months or a year
they would get an education award of
approximately 6
429 dollars
okay thank you
further questions if not uh
representative
rowan
do you want me to sit
here sure
thank you
thank you for the opportunity and if any
of you are interested in serving
in national service or additional
volunteer opportunities please feel free
to contact us
you'd be paid more than what you're
getting here
that's for sure
uh thank you chairman for the record
state representative matt wilhelm uh of
manchester
um
i wanted to address the question of how
much is left in american rescue plan act
funding uh i got in touch with
commissioner taylor caswell who
sent along a link
to the new hampshire state fiscal
recovery fund program obligations uh
this is as of
december 29th 2021
410.02
million dollars
has been allocated at this point out of
a total of 994.56
million
that is available to the state of new
hampshire in american rescue plan act
funding
so it's less less than half has been
allocated at this point
in this request based on the email um
that i think was sent to the committee
uh yesterday from guy eaton who's a
member of volunteer new hampshire's
executive committee there was a request
for
um
the the funding request
would be a total of 750 000
over three years
for other questions
representative
thank you uh first if you could get us a
print of that
that would be great and second the
funding request i'm sorry i thought that
the idea was that the
entire amount that was left
in arpa
unallocated for this would come to this
fund and be used over the years
i think i think the the idea is that uh
this is a limited request of 750 000
it's not the rest of arpa funds so if
it's
uh incorrect in the the bill as drafted
um that is surely the intent that it's
it's limited to
a certain amount it's not all leftover
funds from
uh american rescue plan representative
if that's if that's what you're asking
could i follow up i'm
having a little difficulty here sure uh
so it would not be a one-time transfer
it would be three years
and does arpa doesn't go that long does
it my understanding is go that long
it does
and it could be done you know it could
be done as a one-time disbursement of
750 000 or it could be you know 250
thousand dollars per year over three
years
wrapped indonesian
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking our questions uh so after the
three year period then how would that
work the state would fund it
no i actually think that this
you know the way it's envisioned is that
this is it's very much a pilot program
it could be a one and done you know this
is sort of a stimulus of let's let's get
more
uh
employers on board from across the
public-private non-profit sectors to
join employers of national service to
make it clear that they are very
interested in the talent and experience
of these
americorps and peace return peace corps
volunteers
as well as colleges and universities to
join that
americorps schools of service program so
that
you know
i think
we we are we are very sure based on uh
you know what we've heard from all
colleges and universities and employers
who have
uh attracted and and
these these young people to their
colleges into their
uh businesses
uh that these are great workers and so i
think
this this money is very much let's let's
increase the number of programs that are
participating in in
you know these two existing programs
give them a little bit of cash to to get
it going but this could be this could be
done after three years but what we've
done is change the conversation about
the valuable resource human resource
that
these members can be in the state of new
hampshire
follow up
so
unless i miss it is there a place in the
bill where it says
three years that i missed that or 250
000.
thanks for the question i think the
the
it's a three-year it's three years of
funding
um the funding the fund could continue
on
by looking at philanthropic sources by
looking at uh you know businesses could
donate to that fund
um
you know there could be there could be
additional federal funds made available
down the line for it so i don't think we
necessarily want to close the fund but
we also don't necessarily need to
you know i think it would serve a great
purpose by
existing for three years
and then you know letting the ways and
means committee three years from now
decide you know what's the future of
that fund look like does it need to
continue on or is that something that we
can close down
thank you thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you
for taking my question i i guess have
you gone through the gopher committee
and finance and we're talking a lot
about several thousand dollars i'm
looking at the bill and i can't find an
actual dollar figure in the bill and so
my question is have you gone through
gopher have you gone through
um you know fiscal committee to see
about the appropriation um because my
one concern is section two that says the
commissioner shall credit which doesn't
exactly give the commission a whole lot
of wiggle room to say wait they didn't
appropriate funds i have no funds to
credit so what does he do so i'm a
little concerned about how that plays
out and i'm wondering if you can answer
that question
uh thank you representative for the
question uh you know reached out to
commissioner caswell you know over it
over at gopher
um
you know
i think the idea was let's let's see if
this is something that the legislature
is interested in supporting i mean i
think there are a number of different
routes that this could go to get funded
this was this was one of the one of the
ways that we could do it
follow up so i i guess your idea is just
to establish the fund and then if the
funds become available use it yeah and
if that's the case i'm just a little
concerned about roman numeral two in
here says the commissioner shall credit
state funds received from arpa and it's
a shall statement not a may statement so
that makes it a little
if they don't yeah i guess i'm trying to
figure out how we get that conflict
settled i may not be necessarily opposed
to establishing a dedicated fund for
this purpose but i also don't want to
put the commission a bind where money is
not allocated by the legislature but
he's obligated to
you know you understand the conflict
there
i thank you representative for the
question i think i understand the
conflict um
you know i think the idea is to set up
the fund and get it funded by arpa at no
additional cost to granite state
taxpayers and so
um
this this was a mechanism that going the
legislative route you know filing
legislation was the way that that i
could do it again i think there were
other ways that this could happen
um
you know but i think
you know it was it was one of the
recommendations that was in the service
your workforce commission from 2019 and
you know this this was a way to further
that recommendation
thank you
representative
thank you thank you i'm still trying to
figure this one out now so on
uh i'm one of the gurus for dedicated
funds
uh on this committee
and uh
i don't believe we have ever
created a dedicated fund in which we did
not provide some funding mechanism even
if it was one that said
open to donations which usually fails
so
i was assuming that the paragraph uh
sub
on roman numeral 2 on line 28 to 29
meant that
the commissioner is going to credit all
state funds received from the american
rescue plan for the purpose of the
subdivision to the fund
was the
was the funding mechanism
but
you're talking
you say that 410 million of 900
something which i missed
for this program are allocated that
obviously does not mean the program that
is
that
covers
returning peace corps volunteers and
americorps
that must be
the entire arpa
program
and that would
put 500 million dollars into
into your dedicated fund
if it was interpreted that way
so you're what you're asking for is a
three-year
distribution or of 250 000 a year or
one year of 750.
thank you representative for the
question yes i think that there's
there's some confusion in how the bill
is drafted and how you just summarized
what
uh you know 750 000 in one lump sum or
250 000 per year over three years that
is uh very much the the hope of
volunteer new hampshire uh per the the
request that was sent yesterday
roman numeral would have to be rewarded
to serve the intent of
the bill
mr chairman
followed by representative schamberg
i'm over here i'm the next one
yeah i think i think this is really a
both a drafting question and a
clarification of intent
problem and
the the drafting um
there's no way that you could have
intended that you were that this bill
was going to take all of the leftover
money in arpa no way um the intent was
that money received from arpa by the
commissioner for this program would be
going into this fund
that was the idea and
the lack of
of
specifics relates to
well
maybe the legislature needs to speak to
how much money should come from arpa and
that's what you've spoken to this
morning and you're talking about 750 000
uh max over three years
so
i think
that for those of us who want to
consider this and
perhaps move forward with it that we
need an amendment
that would
uh
would do what i've just described make
clear
the
cap on the limit on the
the amount of money sought from arpa
and uh then that money would go into the
fund which under roman three of this
bill
is uh
allowed where the commissioner is
allowed to accept and credit to the fund
any other gifts donations and so forth
into the fund and who knows maybe it
would be
a fund that would have a three-year life
or maybe it would have a 100-year life
we don't know it may uh you know be very
successful
in stimulating interest
in the private sector that would
generate the funds that would keep it
going
that's my understanding of it maybe you
could comment on and and whether you'd
be willing to offer and
to maybe talk to commissioner carswell
about language and then
have an amendment that we could consider
excellent uh representative thank you uh
for your summary that is uh exactly the
the legislative intent and i think now
with this funding request from volunteer
new hampshire around 750 000 over three
years uh i would be happy to work on an
amendment uh with any members of the
committee uh to to get this to a point
where it's clear
uh and the committee can make a decision
on whether or not they want to recommend
this to the full house
are you all set uh mr chair i
fully support what representative ames
said that i was going to ask the
committee if we can go forward with an
amendment on this
representative aaron followed by
representative
elni
thank you mr chair so just to be clear
and i'm looking at the new hampshire
state fiscal recovery fund program
obligations and which is what you
referred to
because i also got the link from mr
caswell
because i was interested as well and so
what i'm seeing here is that the
the american rescue plan act awarded
994.56 million
in state fiscal recovery funds to new
hampshire
the first half the first tranche
was
for
497.28 million which was
given to the state in may 2021
so of that
we have allocated
410.02 million
and so
yes there's money in the fund obviously
but there's also going to be a whole lot
money um another
497.28 million next year
um or actually this year i'm sorry
um
so yeah i i i just wanted to make that
clear to the committee
because you know it's kind of fuzzy as
to how much money we were allocated as a
state
in total and how much
the two tranches are are
and how much of the first tranche we've
already
allocated
but yeah i think it would make sense to
put it bring an amendment that would be
clearer as to exactly how much money
you're looking for
from the arpa
monies that have come to new hampshire
thank you
that's a statement not a question oh yes
i'm sorry okay
i would believe that's a good idea
all right
uh representative
thank you as i understood this
originally and i have not seen the
letter
and it's not in my email as far as i can
tell
from
volunteer new hampshire asking
specifically for the 750 000
if they sent it
i didn't get it
but
i
what i was concerned with was within
arpa
what part of it was allocated as it came
in in either trance
to
a program that
would fit this categorization i mean the
category that this
this
project
would fit in
and that was the question that i had not
the percentage of all of arpa
when i asked it last time
great thank you representative for the
question
um
i can i can do a deeper dive on that i
think there is a specific category for
workforce development
so i've heard a few requests
here and
i'll make sure that the committee gets
both of them one is
the detail around
how much arpa funds are left in total
and specifically for this workforce
development fund
i think if i could i think that
it is
they it did come in categories we're not
supposed to spend as i understand it
outside of those categories
so what we need is the workforce
development allocation
and how much of it
went in the first tranche and what are
the companies the competition for the
second tranche because of that
and i
i'll get that information around
workforce development i'm not sure
we'll know
you know unless commissioner caswell
wants to share that with everybody
if there are competing priorities
um but we'll certainly we'll know what's
been spent and what is what is left and
if there are any other proposals that
are being considered right now we'll try
and surface those
i think the important thing is
identifying
what you really want the 750 000 and
then if you wanted over
one year or three years as has been said
that is the money that would be funding
this fund
so to me that's the important part
yes
yes representative
yes i want to make a statement not a
question tucker uh i think it's
great
between now and next thursday you have
plenty of time to work out these details
but i want to speak really to the
general thought
of the funds and the importance they can
make to the state of new hampshire
in the north country where i live
there are people who
have stayed around because they went to
franconia college which has long since
disappeared
and they turn out to be the people who
started wren
and
have revived the town of bethlehem
and they're very involved they're
involved people
and the kind of people who volunteer
whether it's for peace corps or other
programs city year
they're people who throw themselves into
projects
we have conservation's core members who
learn how to cut trails and so forth
out of a vermont agency and those people
who stayed around are the people who
make a difference you see them
and
i think the concept of keeping the can
do sort of people
in new hampshire
is a great one and i can't believe you
can't work out these details with this
many days ahead of you and i think it's
like the gi bill
the kind of
good things that happen from these sorts
of really relatively small amounts of
money
can be tremendous for our state so thank
you
any further comments
if not yes representative
chairman i'm just going to
drop off a copy of the service your
workforce commission report that was
assembled
from 2019 to 2020
with the recommendations two of those
supporting employers of national service
and
americorps schools of service are
included
in that final report and i just want to
make sure the committee had copies of
that so i'll drop that off and it can be
circulated
thank you
anybody else
questions saying none thank you thank
you chairman
and i have nobody else listed as
wanting to participate in house bill
1524 right now
so
i would like to go to
yeah house bill 1494
relative to property tax exemption
concerning certain communication service
lease
and
i believe we have somebody from the
uh
from the dr uh from the attorney
general's office or the dre
14.94
my name is james gary i'm the director
of the municipal and property division
of the department of revenue
on bill 1494
the department of revenue does not have
a position
but i am here to answer any questions
you may have
as far as anything we might be able to
help you with
with this bill
questions from the committee on 1494.
representative romney can you your words
just describe the properties that we're
talking about here it's the right-of-way
it's the
public right-of-way is it
can you help us out with that yeah
how is it how is it taxed now
it's a public right-of-way and it's
taxed at the local level
this is a a local tax
that is assessed by each of the 259
municipalities
whether they be cities towns or
unincorporated areas
and they
they each of these 259 municipalities
will
hire their local assessors to go out and
assess this property
and
tax it accordingly
so is it is it just the land that we're
talking about or the the equipment
that's on the land as well uh this is
this is just it's the land and the
equipment
that that's taxable yes
thank you representative tucker
turn you turn your mic on
so sorry
i said a bad example so i wanted to
see um
this is from an assessor who lives in
jefferson which is part of my district
coast five
and i want to know whether what he says
is true
he asked me
to vote itl on this bill
the bill he said would exempt phone and
cable companies from being assessed
on their uses public right-of-ways
this issue has been debated for more
than 20 years and it's become
established that there is taxable value
to the row that municipalities must
value the value is even built into a new
formula for assessing other utilities
such as electric water and gas
there is no reason to unfairly exempt
phone and cable companies effectively
forcing new hampshire pac taxpayers to
subsidize these
private companies
so is what he says true
well it is certainly
what he's saying that it is uh taxable
property is correct it is taxable
throughout the state of new hampshire
it would be it would
uh certainly if we at the d.r.a provide
oversight of local assessors if they did
not put that on the tax rolls it is
something we would uh bring to the
attention of the select board that it
would be a failure of something that if
they did not do that
thank you
thank you for the
representative thank you mr chairman mr
garrity uh
if
this
bill was passed
what would happen to
the property tax rate in
each town that had you said all the all
of the municipalities are
using this local tax so what would
happen to each of their tax rates when
you calculated the next tax rate
when i said each each is usually using
the tax
to clarify that they are subject to it
it only if they if they utilize it only
depends if they have utility properties
that are utilizing the right of way
which i can't
make a blanket statement that that's
true for all 259 entities
however
what assessed value is it doesn't
determine how much a municipality spends
it doesn't determine what their
appropriations are it's merely a
dividing of the pie
so the lower your assessed values the
lower your taxable assessed value
everything else being equal the higher
your property tax rate will be
so for
for every dollar that you exempt from
the rolls is a dollar shift
to the taxable property
so
everything else being equal the tax
rates would go up
any further questions
uh representative romney
um
how easy is it to generate a list of
every one of these towns and how much
what the various uh assessed values are
for this uh that that would be an
arduous task okay that's all that's all
i wanna okay yeah it's it's not any it's
not information we rightly we regularly
have if it is i would have brought it
here today okay it's not something will
we get uh
broken down assessed value by utility
we don't get it broken down by utility
and then right of way so there's no way
to uh easily come up with that what it
would have to be is
manually contacting each of these 259
entities and trying to determine you
know if they had the information then
collecting it okay i understand thank
you
thank you
representative
thank you mr chair to follow up on
representative abrami's comments
is the rate applied by the various
municipalities
equal across the state or does it vary
from town to town
the the tax rates vary from town to town
there's your answer pat
thank you uh we don't have any kind of
fiscal note on this even though it's a
local issue local
uh it would be a local fiscal note
do you have any idea how much of a
revenue shift this
this would be in total
we don't
again we have no way to collect that
information i know i did see a report
that was submitted to the committee
by mr wheeler from the san souci
corporation
and i looked at that which covers a
small section of new hampshire and those
numbers seemed
reasonable to me
so
i'm not sure if you could make a rough
extrapolation but
we could certainly ballpark it but
coming up with an exact figure would be
which would take a lot of work
thank you any further questions
representative yeah
in terms of uh mr san souci's
chart that he gave up
are those numbers the assessed values or
the taxes paid do we know or if so maybe
somebody from
representative mr san souci's company
can answer that question
yeah i would defer it to you okay thank
you
mr wheeler
just as soon as if there's no further
question any further questions of the
representative from the dra
saying none thank you thank you sir
and mr santorini
we want to sit down
and turn on the mic
my name is jim wheeler i'm with uh
sansusi's office and i provided that
report and just wanted to answer the
question
those are assessed values
just want to make sure thank you
any further questions
represent me
it's a little late to be trying to
figure this out but there was something
in our paper yesterday morning
on lebanon is one of the san souci
clients which i realized
we used to have our own assessor
on
there are there is a last mile in
lebanon between lebanon and hanover and
142 houses in it which is going to be
linked to broadband
on by 60 000 of arpa money and
535 000 of comcast money which works out
to 4.2 thousand
200 a home
what
what would be the tax
that
i guess i'd have to go back and get our
our tax to figure out
you're talking assessed value yeah we
were talking assessed value so i'd have
to translate it back to the tax to see
about 20 cents
i made that i said if your rate is 20
cents uh
uh
our tax rate is a lot higher than 20
cents it's 20 dollars and
it was near 29 for a while
dollars
are you all set representing me yeah
yeah i need to spend some time
looking at this and looking at any
further questions
saying none thank you
anything else on 1494
representation
thank you mr chair so for the committee
remember in the last meeting we i talked
about the idea of trying to create an
enablement statute for this to allow to
go town by town to see if towns wanted
to wave that
yeah that was not going to happen
i worked at ols and the drafting of that
amendment was pretty dramatic and pretty
drastic it was basically going to create
where we have like pilot programs for
solar programs those can create they
called it a silent program services in
lieu of taxes and it was a pretty
significant lift um and maybe you know
if someone wants to take that on for a
future bill that may be possible
but under the current bill the way it
was written it would so dramatically
change it i'm not sure it wouldn't be
germaine anymore because it creates a
whole new set section of law so that was
abandoned just to let everybody know
that's why that i i did try to do that
we did try to work through it it was
unable
i am concerned about the bill is written
doesn't necessarily improve expansion
services it gives a tax break and that's
for sure but it doesn't necessarily
approve expansion services so
um
i just wanted to already update on that
because i did bring it up last meeting
okay
any further comments or questions on
1494.
thank you
i want to go to house bill 1509
relative determination of the firearm
victims contribution recovery fund
we have mr buffetti from the attorney
general's office here
morning mr chairman members of the
committee
uh last week there were some questions
about
what state government has done uh after
the frm um
debacle
uh
to and so i can respond to that to the
extent that the committee wants to
hear that
uh so um in 2014 the legislature
passed um a statute it's rsa chapter 21u
which uh deals with interagency
information sharing by financial
services regulators
uh so this was an attempt uh to make
sure that
those agencies specifically
the um
the bureau of of securities regulations
the banking department the insurance
department and the department of justice
who receive consumer complaints related
to financial services issues that
they're talking to each other
and i i can tell you because i was the
consumer protection bureau chief for
nine years uh and i was
i was chief when this statute was passed
and implemented that it has resulted in
much higher level of
uh exchange of information between those
agencies
so the the statute requires that there
will be
um there'll be regular meetings
uh with people from those agencies to
talk about complaints that uh that
they're seeing that may be a mutual
interest to the other agencies those
meetings have been happening regularly
since the statute was passed
there were also common interest
agreements between those agencies to
share the information in some cases the
information has to be kept confidential
so there's there's um
there are terms that would require
certain information
especially sensitive financial
information to be get to be kept
confidential and there has been a
regular dialogue uh with these agencies
uh
especially with uh with the bureau of
securities regulation
um to talk about in uh cases of
investment fraud and so my office and
bsr has worked uh very closely over a
number of years to to make sure they
were talking about cases that they're
looking at they also may have criminal
components and that where they were
working these cases together
there was also a statute that was passed
by uh
by for the banking department
um one of the one of the issues here has
been that by state law the consumer
protection act
which is what empowers the attorney
general's office to to to to function in
this area
contains what's called an um exemption
clause
and so essentially what that says is
that
any
trade or commerce that is under the
jurisdiction of certain agencies like
banking insurance
securities
puc
that that that trade or commerce is
exempt from the consumer protection act
so it in effect ties the hands of the
attorney general so that we cannot act
in those areas
that uh where the trade and commerce is
under the jurisdiction of
of those of those other state agencies
so one of the responses to that was and
i was bureau chief we worked very
closely with the banking department
to pass a a comparable statute
in uh the banking statute that pro that
that prohibits unfair and deceptive
practices and that requires that our two
offices be coordinating in
investigations and prosecutions of these
cases
so i i can say that um
those those were difficult lessons that
were learned i became bureau chief post
frm
most of my nine years as bureau chief i
was focused on making sure
that we didn't
miss
important issues that we needed to be
addressing on a statewide level that had
to do with investment fraud banking
fraud
mortgage fraud and that we were talking
to each other in ways that we could
hopefully uh head off
some sort of a of a bigger issue down
the road
doesn't mean that things won't get
missed it does but it does mean that we
have all
focused on trying to make sure that
we're talking to each other sharing
information and working much more in a
cooperative way to address um issues
that that we may hear about uh and that
need to be
to be addressed by state enforcement
people
questions from the committee
representative romney
thank you mr chair thank you for your
testimony
we have some members here who weren't
here in the first
hearing
uh can you can you just give us uh it
sounded like for not hearing that
that the train is down to track on this
and how just refresh your memories again
how close are we to actual checks going
out
sounds like we're getting there pretty
close uh but can you just
say that one more time please sure so
last week um the director of the of the
charitable trust unit at the ag's office
tom donovan testified before you um this
has been has been uh delegated by
legislation to
to his unit within the ag's office
they've hired someone they have a we
have a 10 million dollar victims fund
we
began just a couple of weeks ago
soliciting um
applications for victims under that fund
we expect to be processing those i think
there's a deadline of of uh six eight
weeks or so before uh so we can process
those with the hope of being able to to
to get money out as soon as the statute
allows us to do so i think that the
money doesn't go out until the end of
the year by statute
but
the process is in place we've hired
somebody we have it on our website we've
put out a press release we've encouraged
those who think that they were victims
of firearm to come forward and to and to
apply for uh the funds uh in that
account
thank you
representative ames
i i asked this question in a preliminary
way when we
were talking about this bill last time
but the it relates to what's available
for public uh review
um
we we've got a process now where
applicants can respond to this new
setup that you have and uh
and request and identify themselves as
victims if that's the right word and
uh identify a claim
an amount sought
and other details i suppose so what's
going to be available
can you speak to the
public records aspect of this thing yes
so certainly the amounts that are paid
out of the fund and to whom they're paid
will be public there has to be
uh
that level of transparency um
the actual uh application information
may contain
some confidential sensitive information
that that should be shielded
from public um
disclosure so i think we're going to
have to look at that you know as it
comes forward but
clearly these are public funds
they
that that the public has a right to know
who ultimately receives them and how
much money they receive
thank you um are there
existing lists of uh
of claimants uh from uh
you know the time when you were there
and on uh that
might also be subject to public review
um
i so i don't know the answer that
question um
there was
certainly people that have come forward
i i know that
that we were that we are aware of
a potential pool of applicants and so as
part of our outreach in launching this
application process
we we sent letters directly to them
so
whether or not they uh apply um
um
we'll have to see
whether or not that's public
that's not a a question i i'm
comfortable answering right now i don't
know the answer to that then there may
be reasons why that they they um their
identities don't become public
information at this point uh but there's
there were certainly people that were
that were public about it and um and if
their names are in the public forum
obviously that's that's information that
we could release
representative
thank you uh
mr chair i beg
permission to ask about this exemption
clause in a more general way
than just this particular this is the
first time i have ever heard the
department talk about it
since i was told that they exempt
anything to do with condominiums
uh
does this also
why does it include condominiums and
does it
on
also include all of the trades and
professions that are regulated under the
office of professional licensure
so representative thank you but so let
me let me kind of circle back to this
issue about condominiums
it
we are not exempt from dealing with
condominiums
um we only deal with a certain aspect of
it so
um
we
we register condominium
projects with the ag's office
what we don't do and it's not that we're
exempt from it it's just we don't have
we don't have a function to do that what
we don't do is resolve disputes between
condominium owners
once the project is developed and the
reason for that is simple this is a
consumer protection step to make sure
that if people if if people are buying a
condominium
that they that they will get what they
were promised in the in the the
statements that were advertising the
condominium so if it says you're going
to have this condominium with a pool and
tennis courts and all of these amenities
we have to make sure that that is
actually what the consumer gets and that
it meets certain standards so it's a way
up front to make sure that the developer
is is fulfilling their promises to
consumers and so we we're very active in
that registration of condominiums and
subdivisions
the exemption clause
is in 358a
section 3 which exempts
trade and commerce under
under highly regulated um
industries uh
parts of the economy
that was the theory of it so again
banking
under the jurisdiction of of state on or
federal banking authorities
insurance state federal or other state
insurance authorities
securities
uh both state and federal uh and and puc
uh so the idea was that because they
were highly
regulated
that
that the consumer protection act which
prohibits unfair and deceptive business
practices generally
that that wouldn't apply to those
i can tell you that the issue of the
exemption clause um
has been a perennial issue although i
don't think it's come up this year but i
think i've been involved in that issue
for nine to ten years testifying in
front of the house commerce committee
um and
representative john hunt
is very familiar with that issue he's
probably one of the experts in the state
on on the exemption clause
and we have gone back and forth with
that
that was a choice that was made new
hampshire sort of is a in a very small
number of states that exempts the
consumer protection act from from
in in in this way
and i've testified to try and change
that exemption clause frankly uh we were
successful in the banking context we
were able to reach a compromise that we
could put the same protections in the
banking statute we haven't done the same
thing with insurance and with securities
but it it does exist um
and it but it is only for those those
highly regulated in terms of oplc
it does not
um so
if
uh if if an if a nurse is engaging
in unfair or deceptive business
practices and the nurse is licensed by
the board of nursing
we can bring a consumer protection act
against that nurse in fact i've done
that um you know that they've actually
you know but you have to you have to
actually be putting out your services
you know publicly that you advertise
that you have certain credentials that
you don't
that could be a potential consumer
protection act and we could bring action
in the ag's office for that
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question i have two questions
the same ones i ask of one of the
sponsors of the bill uh first is
does uh is the current process a
used terminology used by others a make
whole
process that is under the current
process is the
uh person who is defrauded made whole in
any way shape or form
no
and i think that was the answer that i
think you asked that last week to mr
donovan and the answer was no thank you
i
just and the other question is a
philosophical one and uh
um
do you believe that the state has
no liability for the bureaucratic miss
and malfeasance associated with this and
use your term debacle
no uh i i think that there was a a a
failure um
to uh identify the issues
that were going on in frm
um you know there have been lots of
reports that were written about that uh
to try and figure out exactly what
happened there was a lot of finger
pointing uh
and that's not particularly helpful uh
at the end of the day
we needed to fix it and we need to make
sure that it doesn't happen again and
put in in in
place
um systems so that we are talking to
each other and trying to identify
problem areas and it's and it doesn't
get missed because agencies are talking
to each other
thank you sir
thank you mr chair
uh representative schamberg
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question in the public
review we had on this i had a question
that i haven't found an answer yet to
was the state
found
to be in a court of record liable and
thus responsible for the loss
of these monies
that were invested with frm
i i i don't know the answer
uh that i can say with certainty i don't
think so
i i don't i don't think so but i i can't
tell you um i wasn't that familiar i i
wasn't i wasn't doing that work when
firm happened and i was more focused on
trying to fix the problem
i i
i don't know there may have been
lawsuits that weren't but i can't tell
you that there were any ever any
findings by a court of competent
jurisdiction
follow-up
would you believe that's
the same answer i had last week
thank you okay
well i guess that's good
any further questions
i have one
representative
bernstein thank you mr sharon thank you
for taking my question i'm looking at
rsa 359 p4
which uh
there should be an annual report filed
to the director every february first
beginning february 1st 2022
how can i get my hands on that report
uh you can make a request of the
director um if it's a report that's
required um
if you uh
if
i'm happy to try and facilitate that so
if if you if you want i can
uh and i'm not sure what statute you're
talking about
um but
um if you email me i'm happy to uh to
try and ask the director of that reports
available and to make it available to
you
very good i'll do that thank you
further questions
saying none thank you mr buffett
any other
questions on house bill 1509
representative
i'm trying to remember but i believe
that the reason i asked for us to get
the chapter law
for
the fr
rm
bill
so that we could read it on was that
we
there is some kind of some sunset in the
chapter law and
we can't get chapter law anymore
we haven't been able to get chapter law
since
eldon thompson's sold
the rights to our rsas to himself
to his print shop
but they are in the lbao somewhere and i
don't know i presume the attorney
general's office has it
and it would be nice to be able i mean
frequently it would be nice to be able
to get the chapter law do you have the
number of the chapter
no
jim
so representative i
are you asking for the statute that
established this fund
yes and the chapter law that came out of
that i can get that to you and i can i
can email it to the committee great
thank you thank you here
any anything else we need on
house bill
1509 if not
holding the work session on that one
the next is a juicy one
house bill
1565-f and i shouldn't have made that
statement
an act relative to the opioid abatement
trust fund
questions from the committee
we've received a number of
corresponds do we need what else do we
need to address
does the attorney general's office have
any comments on
your
opioid abatement trust fund
thank you mr chairman james buffetti
from the attorney general's office um i
i hope i got almost all of you
uh in email with attachments i
uh the last time there was questions
about if there was any information
from hhs about
drug overdoses
this is probably much more than you
wanted
and it may not be in the form that you
wanted but it there is that i so i sent
uh to all the committee members i could
find by email the new hampshire drug
monitoring initiative
which breaks down some information
geographically
so i hope that was helpful to you
i also because i think there was a
request for this as well but i also
included
two charts which have
the the distribution
uh using the 2020 the 2010 census
figures and the 2020 census figures
these are the um
the 23 litigating subdivisions
uh under the statute 126 a colon 83
that qualify
for
at the ti at the present time the 15
percent
which is how the current statute
is structured so that any opioid
settlement funds that come into the
state or to any subdivision
that 15 percent off the top
go to those
subdivisions that filed opioid
related lawsuits prior to september 1st
and so we made one distribution because
we got that money from them from that
that settlement with um mckinsey
uh it was about 415 000
and it is it was based on the 2010
census because that's what this the
current statute says
um
so so just as a
as a if it's if it's not self-evident
which i hope it was i tried to make it
that way
so you see the numbers for each county
in the first column
belknap 6088
and then you see the actual percent of
distribution that they would get of the
15 percent
so
so because in belknap
um laconia and belmont have
both participating subdivisions then
according to the statute you would
deduct
their numbers from the total number of
people who live in belmont county to get
the belmont share at belknap county to
get the belknap share and the reason you
do that is because if you don't then you
end up double counting people
uh you would count them twice so if you
don't if there's no mechanism for
instance in hillsborough
um you know there was um there's 109 000
people who live in manchester and 86 000
who live in nashua if you didn't do that
then then then then the the
hillsborough county
would be counting those people in
manchester and nashua twice uh and that
and so
mathematically there's no way of getting
to a hundred percent of the population
uh so you have to do that in order to
have a fair distribution of the funds
so
uh so this is the the two thou i just wa
i wanted to show you that the the the
2020 census figures so you have a sense
of how things have changed it hasn't
really changed that much the population
has gone up
by about
50 000 or so people but to see where
those changes are and so
uh with the current statute this is what
we would use
uh as a a distribution formula
um so that for instance if we got 10
million dollars in
then under the current formula 15 of 10
million would be distributed to these 23
counties on with that percent so that so
so carroll county we get 3.6 of
of of that of that money
hopefully that didn't confuse you too
much
but i'm happy to answer any questions if
i did
questions
representative aaron
thank you thank you mr befetti
and thank you mr chair for allowing my
question
so
you you talk about
double counting
but is it true that the counties
have different programs than what the
individual municipalities may have
and that they serve different purposes
well similar they're similar purposes
but they are different programs
sure and primarily because the counties
run the houses of corrections so each
county has a house of correction and
most of them have programs run out of
their houses of corrections that deal
with opioid use disorder
inmates
and so the the town of
of keene
wouldn't have that sign of a program
that's correct
follow-up follow-up
but the counties
is is it true that the counties don't
only just have
um these map programs
through the jail system they have other
programs that are opioid abatement
programs
that they are paying for right now
sure i mean it of course it differs by
county so
stratford county uh which probably has
the most in terms of programming
also they have the the the the suboxone
um
medication assisted treatment kind of
services that they that they distribute
that which is very expensive but they
also have
uh have uh treatment programs that are
provided for inmates while they're
incarcerated but not all counties have
that so it depends it varies county by
county
thank you
questions representation followed by
representative murphy
thank you mr chairman i've been trying
to match this overdose
drug overdose um
from 2021
incidents
across map across all of the towns and
cities
on i don't have any problem with
distributing more to the counties
because the counties add up to the state
and everybody gets to participate what i
have trouble with is picking out
uh 12 cities and one town
on from the rest of the towns
and
city in
in
new hampshire to get
what could be triple funding
once from the county
once from state grants once from their
own
distribution of of 40
for their population
um
and
the
laconia and keen seem to be the two
that have over a hundred and one
overdose
incidents in 2021 that were reported
when you get to the 26 to 100
littleton berlin lebanon tilton milford
bedford gloucester
hooksett
hudson salem playstore
brentwood durham farmington and
five places that are small small
more than five places that are small
enough an area that you can't
see the names without taking more time
to read the chart
so um
and i think given the fact that lebanon
only is in the 26 to 100 that this is
based on where the people
who overdosed were living
rather than where they ended up in
hospital
uh i think it's from it's where the
incident was where the interaction was
with
with whoever the first responders or
whoever for instance if they if they
they happened to be in manchester um
because they went there for
to look for treatment resources but they
lived in dover then uh
and they were given narcan
that it would be a manchester incident
not from where they were living but from
where i think it's from where the
incident i can clarify that with hhs but
that would be my
sense because it because it it has to do
has to do with really where the services
are being administered
um
and so not if not not where they were
where they would claim as their as their
residents
thank you
representative murphy
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
pathetic because i did ask you that
question last week about
the geographic distribution and i
appreciate the charts you did send
and so my question is if you're looking
at to be equitable and fair in the
distribution of the funds available
my question simply i guess would be is
it your opinion that
forty percent of the the increase number
now forty percent of the the the
um
uh the the
people affected by the drug overdoses in
the opioid crisis are in the 23 entities
mentioned because
if i look at the charts
the ems overdose incidences and abuse in
the narcan administration is fairly
diffused throughout the state
so my question is
in fact if the 23 townships or
municipalities represent 40
of
the the need then it's fair but when i
look at the charts in the map it doesn't
make sense to me in some ways so is your
opinion that
is represented within those 23 areas no
thank you okay
um and i think representative army just
read a whole list of give your answer
again
no okay so representative army we had a
whole list of of of communities
that
did not
hire outside counsel to file lawsuits
that would not even though that they
have significant needs hudson
uh happens to be my my neighbor i live
in litchfield so
uh
huds hudson
um
would not
share in that 40 percent um so i mean
here's my
my my point there is this the system
that we have now would say that 85 of
the opioid money
would be available to any community
based on their need
so that we don't need to at this point
decide
uh based on these figures
who has the most need that needs going
to fluctuate so this is over 18 years
right we're going to be dealing with
this so um so what the town of of
of of lebanon has a particular issue
that they want to address
and so
they should be able to come to the
commission we can evaluate all of those
grant applications there's a system
there and decide how to distribute
fairly the 85 percent in a way that does
the most good for the most people that
system is there that system hasn't had a
chance to work yet that system i believe
will work and be more fair to address
the needs that fluctuate over time with
this opioid crisis
thank you and if this bill went through
that 85 would go down to sixty percent
uh yeah
it would be we have forty percent right
sixty percent okay yes correct
uh further questions
represent aaron
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
profetti for taking my question
so
you
uh say that the um there is a system in
place already for these municipalities
to file for grant money
and you know how long it takes between
the time
or what can you explain the criteria
first of all and secondly the time that
it will take for municipality from the
time that they claim
uh an amount to receiving the funds
so as we talked about last week um
we hope that the
that the gel car will approve the rule
so the first
getting it established is the is is the
biggest the biggest chore we're there we
have the rules
done
um we hope that it gets approved in the
next month or so
um the goal and i think it's in the
rules is that we would distribute the
money as quickly as we could and and so
if there was um 500 000
in that account in that fund
that would trigger
the um
the asking for grant applications so
whenever that happened because the money
could come in in in spits uh and
starts and spurs uh so we'd have to uh
we could we get a level of five hundred
thousand dollars at five hundred
thousand dollars we would try and get
that money out as quickly as we could
and so once the rules get approved the
expectation is that we would be sending
that money out on a fairly regular basis
there's a pretty tight timeline from
when we would solicit applications we
have 30 days the commission has a has a
time after receipt of it that they have
to meet and make some decisions the
decisions of course would be
would have to go to the government
council because they would make the
final decisions about the grand awards
that we recommended to them
but i think the hope would be to to get
this money out uh as quickly as possible
on a regular basis during the year
yes thank you mr chair
and thank you again for taking a
follow-up question so
saying if you if gelcar does it
approve
the plans or for your your uh
your method of distributing funds
and then you said there's a there's a
step of going through the executive
council and so forth how long does that
period of time take
well i mean usually
you need a few weeks notice to get
something on the on the government
council agenda
so
we have two point three million dollars
that us that's the sitting in the trust
fund so once the rules get approved
we would have applications we would
solicit applications as quickly as we
could after that within the next few
days
um and then we would receive those
applications the commission would go
through them they would they would they
would try and and sort them out to
figure out
what what what are the best uh the best
uh ways to use that money for the for
the best effect
uh and then make those
uh applications makes that uh available
to the for the governor council to act
on as quickly as possible i mean it's it
is government so you know you're giving
away
essentially government funds and there
has to be a certain process in which to
do that you know so no matter where it
goes i'm assuming if it goes
into a city you know there has to be a
certain appropriations process receiving
and accepting funds figuring out what to
do with it you know there's no
there's no governmental entity that can
take the money and spend it the next
week you know because there's certain
public disclosures of public hearings
there are things that have to happen
uh and so
but but the goal is to try and get this
as streamlined as possible which is what
the rules reflect
uh and that we would hope to get the
money out like i say as quickly as we
could do we have somebody else
questions
representative
thank you what what's the commission
that does most of the work i know that
that the attorney general's office is
always short staffed
uh so
from the ag's office it's me
um
but the commission was established by
the
by the the statute
uh
a colon uh 83-86
and it's an x section 85 which spells
out the members of the commission
it's the governor the attorney general
the state treasurer or the designees the
commissioner of corrections health and
human services one member of the house
one member of the senate
a county attorney county corrections
superintendent county nursing home
supervisor a fire chief a police chief a
designee from a county with a population
of a hundred thousand or more
designate from a county with a
population of of less than a hundred
thousand
uh and then someone from a city with a
population over seventy five thousand
then somebody in the city of town under
seventy five thousand
uh so it's it's this you know there's
all of these members but the commission
has been meeting regularly uh
we i don't know when our next meeting is
it's
it's coming up soon uh but we meet on a
regular basis the
all of the
all of the meeting notices and the
agendas uh and any documents related to
the commission are posted on the hhs
website so if you go on the main page
there's a link for the opioid abatement
commission you click in there and you
should find all of the documents
including
minutes of all our prior meetings
thank you representative romney followed
by representatives
thank you mr chair thank you again
um
so we're talking about the mckinsey
settlement right now 2.7 ish 2.76
million dollars of which would you say
400 114 i think 1000 went out to the to
those 23 subdivisions okay thank you so
follow follow up so
but if we the change this change from 15
to 40 we're really really looking down
the road here as well
and there's probably
even bigger settlements coming down the
road is that safe to say so
um
i'm happy to report that uh we so we
joined a national uh settlement with the
three major opioid distributors
it's uh companies named mckesson
corporation cardinal health and
amerisource bergen it's a national
settlement with 21 billion dollars
and so we've done a sign-on process to
get
support from new hampshire it looks like
all of the
qualifying subdivisions in new hampshire
have joined us in signing on which is
wonderful news so we should get the
maximum amount uh which is approximately
115 million dollars over 18 years
from that settlement alone so that'll be
a steady stream of income that will be
coming in
uh to the state in addition there are
other settlements that are working
through you've probably seen the things
on on uh purdue pharma and the oxycontin
maker and there's a there was announced
that there's a potential
settlement with the sackler family
that would provide for
billions of dollars
we would have a certain amount of that
money would come in uh millions of
dollars would come in and there were
other cases so
uh you know it's it's
probably 150 to 180 million dollars that
could come into the state over the next
18 years
mr buffett
johnson and johnson just announced a
settlement does that affect new
hampshire no
so so johnson so johnson johnson um
they also entered into a national
settlement
with uh with states
we opted not to
join that um we have a trial scheduled
the trial was was was supposed to start
yesterday
but the court had to continue it because
of covert concerns and concerns about
about how do we keep a jury he has a
jury trial
so the case is continued until right
after labor day but we we're still
planning on going to
trial uh here in concord against johnson
johnson
thank you
follow up yeah
thank you again
so the 115 million dollar settlement
for the
against the distributors or with the
distributors
so did any counties or cities or towns
uh were they part of this or is it
or how's this going to work so they so
so under the current statute it doesn't
make any difference if
if if a a county a city or town
filed an opioid related
lawsuit
prior even if they didn't name the
particular defendants for instance none
of them named mckinsey as a defendant
but because there was opioid related
money that under the current statute
even though they didn't they didn't
actually name them they didn't join any
lawsuits against them
they were entitled to their share of 15
so
uh
for those 23 who had filed opioid
related lawsuits as a matter of fact
though most of them probably all of them
did name these three distributors as
defendants in the lawsuits that they
filed all their lawsuits like i said
they were filed in federal court they've
all been stayed in the federal court in
cleveland ohio
with no action being taken on them for
the last two years just to follow
yeah so this is interesting so
because they took action early on
they're going to benefit quite a bit
going forward with this these kind of
settlement numbers correct right i mean
just 15
is is a significant amount they will get
that but remember also
that
that doesn't prevent them from also
applying for grants under the 85 percent
there's no bar
so if if uh if the if the if the town of
um of nashua will get their share the 15
of any money but they could also come in
and ask for
uh for us to consider funding a grant
under the 85 percent there's no bar for
them to do that
thank you that's very helpful
further questions uh representative
spellsbury
thank you mr chairman um attorney
bethetti very complicated topic and i
appreciate the patience you've given the
questions
uh you've clearly indicated your
opposition to the bill
but as my my simplistic understanding is
that the bill proposes two different
things
one is to eliminate the
apparent uh population penalty uh that
hits the counties
and the other is to raise the percentage
that's shared
under this formula
so
i'm just wondering are you objecting to
both of those and if so are you
objecting to them with equal vehemence
yes and for different reasons so
i don't think the math works if you
don't if if you don't exclude uh from
the county's number
those
those communities that were also going
to be getting money then you can't get
to a hundred percent i mean you're
double it's it's not a and i i
i don't think it's a population penalty
it's a double counting people so
manchester
and and nashua um a big chunks out of
hillsborough county that doesn't work so
well for hillsborough county as an
entity because they had their two
largest communities uh join these
lawsuits
but if you don't then then then
hillsborough county would get a windfall
because they would count they they would
count the people in manchester and
nashua in their total the total
population for the county of
hillsborough
even though that they were hillsborough
and and nashua were getting separate
checks
for for their share of the 15
so if you do that
how do you get to 100
you know at the end of the day you have
to have you know this is the population
and we divide up a share of the total
population like the charts show
um so it it what it does it it it and
that's what the current statute does it
it doesn't double count
people
follow up
yes thank you mr chairman
i understand your logic
about double counting and windfall
i'm not totally
sure that i'm convinced
as
representative omni
indicated before the counties in the
aggregate comprise the entire state
and
they have their own programs
you know to the extent for example that
those are administered through their
jail operations they
benefit all of the communities within
the county
without regard to whether one city
within the county happened to be a
litigant
but
why couldn't we do both why couldn't we
accord weight to each county according
to their full population
so as to give
a relative benefit for the probable size
of their program and its cost
while at the same time recognizing that
these 13
cities did in fact take the initiative
to litigate
why can't we do both
so you know in in some cases
in some of the smaller towns
you know some of the smaller counties
with smaller towns
that might
might make some sense to me
i i
i don't want to speak for manchester but
i'm going to guess having worked closely
with the with the city attorney in
manchester that they
would object to them getting
less money because they manchester and
nashua do have a lot of of opioid
related programs that they run a lot of
people go to those cities from other
places in new hampshire looking for
services
so um i mean i i do think that that you
could certainly you could certainly
figure this out i mean you could give
all the money to the counties you know
you could say we're going to just give
all we're going to just give the money
to the counties and let the counties and
the cities you know figure out how they
want to share that
you could do that that's a policy
question for this legislature
my
my my biggest concern was that
that to to single out just those who
filed lawsuits
to the exclusion of others
is profoundly unfair it doesn't address
the need so because you hired an outside
law firm on a contingency fee basis and
they filed a a complaint
that's all you did that's i mean that's
all you did in this case so
um
and that they then get a windfall
because they did that
uh to the exclusion of communities that
didn't
um doesn't seem to be fair and it
doesn't address
the problems that exist in other parts
of the state where they didn't file
these lawsuits they shouldn't be
penalized at this point because really
this is about abating a crisis and
stopping people from dying of of opioid
overdoses and so they're dying in hudson
and they're dying in manchester but
because hudson didn't file
they shouldn't get a disproportionate
amount of money to manchester because
they did hire outside counsel who filed
a complaint on their behalf that's my
that's my major objection
thank you
this is a work session
you're the prime sponsor on this
and
if there was a public hearing
you got me
representative
thank you mr chair
i'm trying to grasp understand i miss
the public hearing so i'm trying to get
catch up to speed here but as as the
exists now 85
of the fund is used for the disbursement
those funds are dispersed are used for
basically directed fires right allow
people to apply for grants and apply for
programs
and and be able to take care of
immediate needs of what's going on in
the you know a dynamic response to the
to this opioid epidemic is that correct
in my understanding so not people well i
mean communities i understand community
so it would be it'd be for 85 would be
available to any
any political subdivision in the state
who had an idea now it has to be with
one of those approved uses for opioid
abatement has to be for opioid abatement
but
they could they could come up with a
very different idea and the the and so
what you know what goffstown proposes
may be very different from what berlin
proposes and that's fine you know but as
long as it's one of those approved uses
uh then they could apply uh and they
could be considered for
their share of the 85 percent and should
i i should say also remember the state
is taking no money here you know uh in
in other states the state took a cut of
the money
uh we opted not to do that we wanted as
much as possible to go
for abatement of the crisis so that we
could get this money out now some of the
money may go to state agencies
my guess is that commissioner hanks is
probably going to be looking for funding
for the state prison system
and there may be programs at hhs there
may be other things so state agencies
can certainly apply but they would be in
an equal footing to
to hillsborough county
who applied for funds
thank you one follow-up
so just let you know uh
jalcar which i serve on already canceled
their meeting for friday they pushed it
off to the 18th which will be the next
meeting day
thank
aaron
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question i'm curious that 13
litigants
that are gonna
get a settlement uh can they be refused
these funds that are set aside
as it as it sits right now the 13 so i
mean
the entities that that are going to get
a separate settlement
can they be denied
these funds the the 85 percent
i apologize i'm not sure i understand
they apply
if the city of manchester for instance
gets a settlement
specific to a certain agreement
and they apply for funds
that
this
this settlement will
be in the pool can they be denied those
funds through the process of application
sure i mean any application can be
denied and there's no there's nothing
that says that the commission would
recommend funding of any particular
project but
but if manchester got a separate
settlement under state law that money
has to go into the opioid abatement
trust fund
so if manchester got a settlement with
with with a opioid manufacturer over and
above it
the state law requires that all opioid
settlement funds go into the opioid
abatement trust fund and that the 15 off
the top get distributed by population to
those litigating subdivisions and the 85
percent is going to be used by the state
for opioid abatement purposes so
so
manchester
they could i suppose they could
try and do a separate settlement but
they couldn't keep the money they would
have to give it to the opioid abatement
trust fund
are you all set
further questions
representative romney
don't know beat this to death but
so let's just use the johnson johnson
example because we're doing this on our
own
as a state
so just just to reinforce this these 23
subdivisions although the ones that are
going to get that 15 only still those 23
for the johnson johnson there were no
other litigants
on that
for johnson johnson
um
well
there so there were these 23
subdivisions who filed opioid lawsuits
prior to september 1st 2019 right
they uh and all of them i believe named
johnson johnson and jansen but um
interestingly there were five school
districts
uh in this state who also filed opioid
lawsuits
but they filed them after september 1st
2019 so they don't qualify to share in
the 15 percent
by state law all right so just get the
tentacles a little bit more it's a
little more complicated okay now the
interesting it's it's an interesting
question about j and j right because
we're not
we're not accepting the we're not
joining the national settlement
so interesting question is
what happens to those cases that the
subdivisions filed against them that are
now stayed in federal court in cleveland
um i'm hoping that those counties and if
there are people here that that talk to
the counties that they encourage their
council to have those cases remanded
back to new hampshire for trial because
we're going to trial they could do the
same thing they could go to trial
um but that's up to them and their
outside the national council what they
decide to do but as it stands now
you know there would be there could
potentially be
uh
24 trials against j and j in new
hampshire because we're going to go to
trial against them
the only way that the subdivisions can
resolve their case is to go to trial
uh or to try and settle it with them in
some way but
so i'm hoping that they will actually
have their cases remanded back to
federal court in concord and try their
cases like we are okay thank you
representative
thank you mr chair just
from my understanding of federal court
activities the federal court could also
deny all those and combine them into one
large case um
file and
to heck with it
and that's sort of what they did so it's
this they call it this multi-district
litigation some of these these these
huge uh tort cases so
so every
every case that was filed against by a
political subdivision in the country
they all were consolidated in one court
with one judge in cleveland ohio and
those case
cases have basically been been sitting
there doing nothing he's the judge has
tried a couple of cases but they've been
sort of these test cases but there are
thousands of cases that are sitting in
the cleveland mdl that have stayed that
nothing's happening with them
and at some point the judge is going to
have to do something with them you know
he can either try them in cleveland so
sullivan county could have a trial in
cleveland
on their case against j and j or he
could send them we manda back to new
hampshire for a trial in front of a
federal court here in concord
follow up mr chairman
yes
i don't understand what damage was done
to a school district
when the services provided
to the individual were provided by the
community not by the school
how did they get where's their standing
well
i mean standing's a different issue
whether they can prove any damages you
know again is another issue as well i i
mean
listen anyone can file a complaint and
um but and because representative
because there's been no litigation in
those cases right we litigated those
issues we had hearings on the
defendant's motion to dismiss our
complaint and that was litigated that's
what i mean when i say that these these
jurisdictions never litigated anything
because the cases have been stuck in
this federal court in cleveland so you
know it's very possible that if this
these cases went forward against the
school districts that they would have
had motions to dismiss and the judge
would have to rule on those
follow-up
since we're a dylan rule state
doesn't that
kind of i mean doesn't that kind of
already say that the separate suits
black standing i'm sorry i missed the
first part of your question since new
hampshire is a dillon rules state
and the towns and cities and school
boards
don't have anything
that don't have any ability to do
anything that the state doesn't say that
they can do doesn't that kind of
preempt their ability to file these
suits
i'm just curious you know actually uh
you're on to something uh and uh it's so
i doesn't i wouldn't preempt them
the ability to file it it could uh it
could prompt the state to go to court to
say these estate claims you can't bring
these claims um we've not chosen to take
that we've chosen to try and uh and and
work with the cities towns and counties
to try and and figure out a way to do
this but we could have
moved to extinguish all of these
complaints filed by cities towns
counties school districts we just didn't
want to we thought there was more
helpful in the long term to work
together and trying and you know come
together on this thank you sir thank you
mr chair for that
any further questions
thank you thank you mr buffetti
anybody else want to contribute
to house bill
1565 with questions or requirements
saying none
representative aaron yes
i know that
county manager ferland had sent us some
information as well and i was wondering
if he may come up and speak to the
documents that he sent along to us
the accounting manager from
berlin
sullivan sullivan yes
and if you
sense it
close to lunchtime
uh if you would
concentrate on any new
information and then we can ask
questions thank you
all right thank you mr chair ladies and
gentlemen of the committee uh derek
ferlin the sullivan county manager
i did send an email with a couple of
attachments earlier this week
i would like to
elaborate a little bit to make sure that
there's um
if you have any questions or if there's
any misunderstandings about what i
provided but i'd also like to
also respond to what i just heard from
mr befetti
in general with the documents i provided
it was an attempt to i think reframe
this discussion about fairness versus
effectiveness
i think it's possible
to have a fair
distribution but one that would not be
very effective conversely i would argue
that an effective distribution would
also be inherently
fair
speaking of the issue of fairness the
population penalty or the double
counting it's there are two sides of the
same coin
my position is that the population
penalty is inherently unfair
um
sullivan county population of about 44
000 people
roughly 30 percent
from the city of claremont alone
the city of claremont decided to join
the lawsuit
so therefore sullivan county share is
decremented by the population of
claremont
if you look at the sullivan county
department of corrections population
today you won't be surprised to see that
about 30 percent of our population
is comprised of people from claremont
so the opioid abatement programs and
activities we run
services population we don't submit a
separate bill to the city of claremont
we are responsible for those programs
and i suspect most counties in the state
are in the same situation with a
proportional share
of their inmates
from municipalities that may or may not
have joined the lawsuit
so that's the importance of making sure
that we get our full calculated share of
these funds to make sure that these
programs
are offered to those citizens as well
it's a compromise solution and i
mentioned that in my in my letter
it's not a matter of getting to a
hundred percent as mr buffett mentioned
it's it's uh if you establish a pool of
funding that needs to be distributed yes
that's how the hundred percent just
doesn't work
the revised formula in this in this bill
is a direct calculation
for each of the 23 entities that decided
to join the litigation prior to
september 1st 2019
because we have counties and
municipalities
that's the reason why this direct
calculation results in a bit of a
mathematical anomaly it's not a perfect
solution
but i would i argue that it's far more
fair than the legislation has currently
written in rsa 126
that is unfair so if fairness is our
guiding principle
um
i firmly believe that fixing the
population penalty is an absolute must
as to the
question of whether these are equitably
distributed with a 40 allocation factor
i provided two attachments from the same
data set that mr befetti referenced the
state's drug monitoring initiative
attachment one is a color-coded map
showing the overdose deaths in 2021
the bright colors jump out
and it proves that roughly
50 percent of the deaths last year in
this state
were from seven municipalities those
same seven are among the 13 that joined
the litigation so
i i think a reasonable person would have
a hard time arguing that overdose deaths
is probably not the most important
metric when it comes to the opioid
crisis after all it's about lives saved
and so if half of the deaths are
occurring in just
seven of these municipalities i'm sorry
of the 13.
i misspoke the 13 municipalities that
are part of this lawsuit
comprise 50 of the deaths last year
if i'd had time to go back beyond 2021 i
would have i just between last wednesday
and this wednesday i didn't
so
the revised funding formula is going to
provide a proportional amount
of settlement dollars that is very
roughly in line with overdose deaths
that makes a heck of a lot of sense i
think that's an effective way to quickly
and effectively distribute the funds
where they are needed most
without waiting for weeks and months of
bureaucratic processes again
the commission's going to operate in the
best interest i think of the residents
of this state but as mr buffett pointed
out it's government
it's going to inherently take a lot of
time
and i don't think it's an exaggeration
to say that this issue is literally one
of life and death
um
again go back to the to the overdose
deaths
um
so if the 40 allocation factor provides
a greater share of resources to the
communities that experienced fifty
percent of the overdose deaths last year
i think that makes a heck of a lot of
sense
attachment two
was the the color-coded map that showed
where the ems
overdose and abuse incidents were
and it's hard to calculate a specific
number because the data are aggregated
and they're binned
so i assumed a midpoint for every
category
and for again for the 13 municipalities
on that map they account for
of all of the ems uh
overdoses and incidents
so again whether you're talking deaths
which is 50 percent or
responses which is 78
i think it makes a lot of sense to
provide a greater share
and that's what this formula in the
house bill does
one other point that really
has not come out either the public
hearing or the subsequent work sessions
mr befetti has characterized our joining
of the national litigation as all we did
was sign on the dotted line
i mentioned in the public hearing that
that's not true we spent hundreds of
hours with our national attorneys
helping with the negotiations that are
going on in the in the case in ohio
um
validating past claims detailing future
abatement programs and their
evidence-based efficacy that we expect
to achieve
and so again hundreds of hours and that
was just for sullivan county i suspect
the other 23 have done much the same
an important part of that is back in
2018 when we decided to join this
national lawsuit there was no trust
the trust wasn't created until last year
so at that time the state had only taken
legal action against just a handful of
defendants i don't know if it was three
or four
and there was no expectation that the
state was going to share in any of the
proceeds
should they have resulted in any kind of
legal claims um
in our favor
so the only hope that we had at that
time
of getting any funding to help with our
local programs was to join the national
litigation so it wasn't a case of well
that's all we did it was our only option
it was our only option of trying to
obtain a share of the litigation that we
knew was going on nationally
and one other point again i just want to
make sure we're clear when mr buffett
says that this this revised formula
provides more funding to the 23
to the exclusion of the others that
simply is not true
uh the 40 allocation factor as was noted
by some members
means that 60 percent still goes to the
trust that is not the same thing as
saying to the exclusion of to the
exclusion of would mean that nobody else
gets anything
and so we were very careful in the
crafting of what would the number be
because the 40 factor quite frankly was
a number on a spreadsheet it could it
could have been something different but
we wanted to land somewhere that we
thought was equitable
and fair and still provided ample
resources for those
numerous communities that decided in
spite of the fact that they had a
15-month window and the bar was very low
uh to not join this national litigation
and i think that we've achieved that uh
the pie charts show
how that mckinsey settlement was
actually distributed uh versus how it
would be distributed and any future
settlements would be distributed
and i really hope mr befetti and his
team
actually put the wood right to johnson
and johnson i hope that when this case
is heard later this year
they emerge victorious
um
i provided a couple of links to some
recent articles to suggest that the that
might not be as easy as it sounds uh
johnson and johnson prevailed in
california and in oklahoma two states
that i'm going to assume have
significant resources at their disposal
on behalf of the state to try those
cases and so far johnson and johnson is
2-0
and so if if new hampshire tries that
case and loses
we get nothing and so that at that point
the math becomes very simple fifteen
percent of zero is zero eighty-five
percent of zero is zero
forty percent of zero is zero
so it doesn't matter you know we can
haggle about it all we want but if if we
try and lose
the trust gets nothing
the national settlement could be our
best and only hope in some cases to
provide funding that will benefit
everybody
whether it was the 23 entities that
decided to take action or the 200 odd
entities that decided to to not they
still have a shot via the trust
so i think that's
important to note i think the the
the methodology and the rationale behind
the the adjustments
um when you look at the data and i'm a
big fan of data-driven decision-making
uh where half of the people in this
state died last year those communities
are going to get more funding directly
without having to navigate additional
layers of bureaucracy and if we're
really worried about helping with this
problem we should be worried about the
the best way
maybe not necessarily the fairest way
but if we do it the best way i think
that's going to be inherently fair
thank you for your time i'm happy to
take any questions
thank you i have this trouble with both
charts though yours is a lot harder
because it was very fuzzy
as it came through it's impossible to
read
but on they do look similar
on there is this enormous
on
1 to 25 i can't read it on yours but i
could read it
on
on his
one to 25
incidents
and then
all the way up to a hundred and then all
the way up to 200 and such and you're
taking a median which
middle point which may or may not be
real
did they refuse to provide
actual data
for each municipality which i'm i'm much
more concerned with the municipal
problem because a lot of the
municipalities that i thought should
have
joined this lawsuit if they knew all
this stuff was coming
would
have been left out
thank you for the question i did contact
the
people that maintain the data on that
website i did get a response and the
response was the data are aggregated if
you want it disaggregated you have to
contact these other people and that was
as of friday last week i didn't do that
because i didn't think i'd have time to
get it and make sense of it so yes i did
make an assumption by taking the
midpoint of that pooled uh of those
pooled categories
you could argue whether that was
reasonable or not so the the 78 percent
could be a plus or minus i suspect it is
a big plus or minus but i think it
proves the point though that the
majority whether that's vast majority or
a simple majority of ems overdose and
abuse incidents occurs in those 13
communities i think it'd be a hard point
to refute even with the limitations of
that data set as presented
thank you i'd disagree with that but uh
can the committee ask to get this stuff
disaggregated so that we've got some
idea of
distribution across the municipalities
we do have the problem that the more
rural municipalities probably didn't
report things that got reported
in the
larger ones but
would you um
take it upon yourself to check with hhs
and see if they could provide that oh
boy
apparently this is coming out of the
medical examiner's office or that's just
the deaths
so the other one is ems
so that's two places i i can i can try
since we now have tomorrow and friday
except they may not be working friday
further questions uh representative
thank you mr chair real quick so
i i'm worried about dynamic i spent a
decade as a cop and i know that drugs
don't stand still they move
and from community community the new
drug that comes up maybe show up in a
different part of the state
how does
under the change that's proposed how
does we deal with that dynamic nature
like all of a sudden sullivan county
solves its problem because it gets us 40
and it deals with its problem and it no
longer has an issue but we're locked in
to this 40 percent
over the next 18 years right so my
concern is about dynamic nature of drugs
and dynamic nature of of uh communities
right so again as we talk about
workforce housing and things that are
going on that communities change and
people move and and i'm a little
concerned that at least the 85 percent
that can be targeted and focused on our
communities that have the most
significant problem and as that target
moves it can adapt
um whereas i'm not sure under the
proposed bill that that would do that so
can you respond to that and answer that
yes uh thanks representative lang for
that question well just bear in mind
that the trust will still have roughly
half the funds so i think
it does preserve a great deal of
resources for whether it's the other
communities or a changing landscape as
you're referring to i think that would
be one way
to make sure that we can still respond
in other in other ways
i can tell you in sullivan county we're
we're establishing the first uh recovery
housing facility in the county uh we're
probably just about a month away from
cutting the ribbon on that um that's
going to be a 30-year commitment for us
based on the financing that we had to do
to put in place for that project that's
one example just for our county
of of um
of the commitment that will extend
beyond this 18-year settlement that we
hope to have some of these funds provide
additional programs that will be offered
at the sober housing location
as far as the changing landscape of
drugs
this is an opioid related settlement so
the dollars are laid out by statute what
the eligible purposes are so even if
there's a new drug that we haven't
conceived of yet or if it's
in response to meth or bath salts or
anything else
i think those are kind of two separate
issues i don't know that the trust
commission would adopt or amend its
rules to address those other
contingencies but i will say and this is
another point that we haven't talked
about a lot there is a reporting
mechanism that's already established in
the original legislation
every year the 23 entities that receive
funds have to report back to the
department of health and human services
how those funds were used
dhhs in turn has to provide an annual
report i believe it ends up at the
attorney general's office among others
i would think that as part of that
accountability process there could be a
way to say well look
hillsborough county or sullivan county
we don't like how they're using their
funds we don't think they're being used
in accordance with the law
we think that they're you know
they're just
they're being frivolous with those funds
there should be an accountability
mechanism and i hope that there would be
such that an if entity didn't need the
money they wouldn't take it but that's
an individual matter i would think for
each of the 23 entities and how the
commission
the department and the attorney
general's office decides to deal with
the data that they receive from those
annual reports about how the funds were
spent
the law currently is silent on what
happens if there's considered to be a
violation um that the the money was
spent not in accordance with the uh
the programs as laid out so
i don't know what the what the recourse
would be um
but i think that there's a mechanism in
place to at least open the aperture and
have a conversation about the funds
being used appropriately or
inappropriately as the case may be
thank you very much
further questions
represent ames
yeah um so
under the present system
before this bill
those that
were are part of the 23
will get a piece of a 15
and the rest of the money
will be available
to applicants
who will apply
pursuant to the process that we've heard
about that's being set up
that's the way i understand it so in
your case
sullivan county will get a piece of the
and then it's eligible
to apply
for a piece of that 85 percent
and if
the application is solid and
the
um identification of reasons for
needing
a larger slice of that 85 percent
are stated there are more deaths or
whatever
that
sullivan county will then get
more money above the allocation that got
in the first instance
and i i wonder why
we would want to freeze in
to place not only that 15 but 40 percent
going forward
um
that is based on
uh
the filing or lack of filing
of uh of
complaint complaints by council that are
not charging anything
but does take some time to respond to
questions produce produce data i
understand that
why we would
set up that forever system or until
another legislature changes it i suppose
in place of a system that will
enable grants to be issued based on
the application the merit of an
application
in which
a sullivan county or a claremont or
manchester
uh could
make its case
against all other cases and get a share
of the money
another way of saying this is why even
is a 15 allocation
a reasonable thing to freeze into
statute
thanks for the question so are you
asking me to comment on the
why 15
uh well let me let me say why are you
pushing for 40 given that context well
the the 15 percent as as was discussed
in the previous meetings was
100 percent arbitrary
it was a 70 15 15 allocation model that
was suggested by uh the judge in ohio
said for the states that are going to
set up
trusts which they were pushing states to
do
as part of the negotiation on the
national front they said if the state
has a trust and the defendants have
assurances that the trust will protect
those funds and ensure that they're
spent on opioid abatement activities
you'll get more money so that was the
the rationale behind pushing everybody
to establish trust
the 70 15 15 was simply a default
suggestion
so
i guess based on the data that i
presented from the states database
there's a lot more rationale that you
can defend based on a 40 allocation
factor in this bill than there is for
the 15
certainly if we look at over overdose
deaths as the primary metric
we should be interested in putting more
funds where it's going to have the
greatest impact and save the most lives
so
that was
that's that's the rationale pure and
simple is to get more funding directly
to those communities and not have to
wait
for weeks and months to submit a grant
process have the commission
approve it and then have it be further
approved by governor and executive
council i think it's a matter of
efficiency and effectiveness and to
provide resources directly where the
problem is
and i think that the data substantiate
that
any uh representative
thank you mr chair
um it would there be a difficulty in
making
two pools of money one for the counties
and one for the municipalities
and not restricting it to a
percentage for the municipalities in
that way
the population is essentially counted
twice like you would like
and
by my
rude calculation the counties receive
about two-thirds of the funding from
this mckinsey settlement
so maybe maybe that's an idea we could
toss about to
separate the counties and municipalities
so you're not competing
for that
funding i don't know just an idea
thanks uh representative gamarlo uh we
spent a lot of time coordinating with
the 10 counties and the 13
municipalities that were part of this
the overarching concern from the
municipalities was that any adjustment
was going to come at their expense
which is what led to this the the
process of doing a direct calculation
for each entity that way
and i know mr buffett alluded that the
city of manchester's share would be
reduced that's not the case
they would get their full share based on
their population and the counties get
their full share based on their
populations the direct calculation
method was really the only way that i
could
think that would be a reasonable
justifiable process and formula
even though it does as we've covered
result in this mathematical anomaly of
double counting
i still think that's a less
bad outcome than trying to share and get
to this 100 percent pie where
where the counties are absolutely
penalized
unfairly
follow-up
it just appears that
not much of the money has been dispersed
and that it sounds like there's going to
be
more settlements as time goes on
and
and to representative lang lang's piece
about the shifting
complexity of the problem
it just seems like
at this point
due to the population size of those
cities they would get
what they needed and then so would you
know a smaller place up in
representative tucker's area
it seems like we should put aside that
these 13 municipalities had a problem
and that
now more and more other
more and more other municipalities do
and we should just share it there's
going to be enough to go around in
from the testimony i've heard
my perspective
any further questions or comments
so you said 70 15 15. okay i'm a little
thick so
the 85 gets split
to 70 15 and the other 15 we understand
you said seven what is the other 15 oh
that yes you're talking the default
model the 70 15 15 was 70 percent to the
trust 15 to the state 15 to the entities
that sued uh mr buffett mentioned that
the state dumped its portion into with
the 70s so the 85 is the 70 and the 15.
right so that was the ohio that was
there the judge's recommendation but we
didn't follow that we just well we did
but the state then decided to put its
share into the the trust pot got it
thank you
further questions or comments
saying none then i'm going to close the
work session on house bill
1565 and we'll be
attending
going back to the work session next week
next thursday
saying that it's 12 30
i'm gonna take a break for lunch
in
45 minutes and we'll be back here at
quarter after one
we have three more bills
i'm going to open the works session on
house bill 1430-fn-a
repealing the tax on rentals of motor
vehicles under the meals and rooms tax
and
from the members
what additional information
do you want
do we require any additional information
mr chair we have somebody from
enterprise rent a car here that may want
to speak
sorry
saying mr chair we have somebody from
enterprise rent-a-car who may want to
say some words
come on up
good afternoon chairman major and
committee members thank you for having
me today
uh
i've been working with my colleague tom
prasall and uh he was keeping me updated
from the um from the session last week
that
uh it might be helpful to make myself
available today to the committee if
there are any questions uh on the rental
car fleet
in new hampshire by number of locations
or a number of overall vehicles
or to make myself additionally available
to discuss
any transactions and comparing
mass new hampshire residents versus
out-of-state uh
customers that that the car rental
industry sees so i just wanted to
introduce myself travis allen with
enterprise rent-a-car
and make myself available for any
questions relative to the car rental
industry that may help you as you
consider this piece of legislation
representative romney
thank you chair thank you
so i know some data was handed out
last week
or stated anyway
that
that there's a lot more
local people
renting cars
new hampshire residents
than out of staters
and i said well i asked well where'd the
data come from they said from enterprise
so but i know enterprise has a kind of
unique model i mean you're you you have
you have offices everywhere and you your
model is to do
the local stuff i mean
when you deal with car dealerships that
they have and i've
i've experienced that
they'll pick you up and they you get the
paperwork and then when you come back
they'll drop you back home
so yes your date is going to show that
there's a lot more local
um but
i i have to be convinced that's that's
my my feeling is that that's not the
case with the others avis you know hurts
whatever
so can you add some clarity to that
please
i'd be happy to thank you
uh yes the the data um
that that that was probably shared with
you was enterprises data but to give
some contrast and as you referenced as
we've spoken earlier about your
experience you know renting from the the
enterprise in exeter
uh our largest uh you know the one of
the other largest rental car companies
is hertz and if you
looked at hertz's locations in new
hampshire they have nine locations i
hope that's correct i i did an internet
search
last week they have nine locations in
new hampshire but
whereas the enterprise model has been
successful of servicing the local towns
and cities it's a successful model
overall for the industry of hertz's nine
locations uh their only one that's at an
airport uh is the one at manchester um
so they have eight locations uh you know
between salem uh manchester off airport
northampton laconia nashua glenn keane
and claremont so
uh you know of the nine locations i
don't know what their associated fleet
sizes at each location are vis-a-vis
their location at manchester uh but i
can speak to enterprises and over the
last 12 months the enterprise rental car
fleet in new hampshire has been
approximately 3 500 vehicles
we have 34 locations across the state of
new hampshire
and only one airport location which
predominantly services uh out of out of
state uh you know customers
um our fleet at manchester airport is
400 vehicles so for 400 vehicles so of
our 3 500 vehicles that we operate
in the state of new hampshire
i wasn't a math major but i think that's
around 12 percent maybe a little bit
less
uh is is at an airport location and if
you
were to look a little bit deeper and
peel the onion back a little bit a
little bit more
we have 116 vehicles at our hookset
location
we have
150 vehicles at the keane location
uh
you know those are local residents you
know a tourist
very rarely i would assume would get to
keen
you know into new hampshire get to keene
and that's oh i think i need to rent a
car those those are you know local
residents businesses
who are renting cars and the majority of
our transactions
in new hampshire are to
new hampshire residents and citizens
a little follow-up follow
so how many sites do you have 34 34 in
new hampshire
and the hertz is follows you a second or
you haven't you didn't check the other
ones it hurts a second uh to my
understanding yes right
now want to follow up follow up so
uh
i lost my thought
do others have the same relationship
you guys do with
all of the auto dealerships for
car car you know
replacement cars while cars are being
repaired
can't speak for all of them uh
avis and budget
they do have some home city is what what
the industry calls the off airport
locations but hertz uh maybe about 20
years ago
uh their branding is called hertz local
edition and the we we compete for the
same type of customers with the
dealership uh you know the dealerships
to to use us when their customers need
uh in effect the loaner vehicle and then
also with the major you know the
insurance companies when in the event
there's an automobile accident to
provide transfer replacement
transportation
so is it
it sounds like if it's a good percentage
of your business
that the car dealership or the insurance
company is actually paying
the
cost of the vehicle plus the tax is that
correct
that would in most circumstances yes
that would be correct
thank you
further questions
if not i have a question um
do the surrounding states maine
massachusetts
and
let's say uh
vermont
do they also have a tax
on these rental vehicles
yes they do
and of the three states is it just one
simple tax or does it vary
it varies the tax rate varies across
all of the states that you referenced
yes
thanks
follow up on that follow up so let's
talk about that
i mean i traveled just about every state
in the country when my job for over
for years
and
the eight and a half percent is a
bargain
to me
you go to most airports and they tech on
they take on all these other fees
you know
battery replacement fee
tire you know i mean it's unbelievable
sometimes
what you pay for the car rental equals
what you're paying taxes and fees it's
equal to the rental cost itself
so
i mean
would you
would you agree that we're a bargain in
terms of our tax rate
that's a good question and uh it's
i think it's
maybe a little more complex than a yes
or no that it's a bargain when you fly
to an airport there's
traditionally concession fees and very
you know what you see on a rental
agreement receipt if you run it at an
airport across the country
there there will be different concession
fees airport access fees that are the
cost of being a concessionaire
at the airport
the the overall tax rate
um
it's about new hampshire's about middle
middle of the pack it's it's not the
worst but it's not the lowest tax rate
um so
uh but but to your point if you just
look at
which many of you all which many of you
may do when you when you do travel out
of state you'll see a an itemized
receipt at the airport that looks very
different uh in most states
comparatively to if you rented from one
of the
local
enterprise locations or carbon locations
in your in your town where you live if
you if you rent it at an airport
mr chair may follow
just just
the worst was san francisco
they have the shuttle train that goes
around
and
the last stop is the car rental
places
25 bucks
and
i i actually questioned that fee one day
and she said well it used to be like
five bucks
but but the sam but san francisco proper
puts that tax on that
and it and it's like every they're
looking for money they just keep on
raising that that tax let's
let's get to taurus i mean let's get to
travelers i mean that's what it is we
don't have that philosophy in new
hampshire you know it's straight tax
and we don't we don't allow
these add-ons but i guess there's really
no question there would you believe
i have one further question if the tax
was removed
would you be renting more cars
i believe so yes
um
represent malloy mr chair thank you
this is a maybe a question for the group
and clarification did we not pass a
uh attacks on ride-sharing
companies
as well
last year we did okay
thank you uh
but it so would this would this bill
apply to the ride sharing companies as
well because it just says
uh rentals of generally rentals of motor
vehicles and
would there need to be a specific
uh
codicil in here that refers to ride
sharing and all the other
that's my question we have the dra
king
did you hear the question
thank you thank you for my taking my
question thank you
thank you chairman thank you committee
members
um
guy from enterprise would you fill out a
pink card
it's coming it's coming okay
kane the question is
is the tax
applied to
motor vehicles rental
as well as the right shares
vehicles
main one from the department of revenue
so um from my understanding is looking
at the uh the current bill it removes
the reference to renter
uh from the bill and um
to be honest i have not looked into the
the right sharing but then i do have a
note here that when i was researching
this that the definition of renter would
mean any persons who for
any for consideration paid to another is
provided a vehicle and rental agreement
so if this renter here applies to the
right sharing
business so then removing this
reference to renter will remove uh
the tax from that as well
this is all repealed mental facilitator
and
also it would apply to the facilitators
well no yes
it is it's in the bill okay yeah right
yeah
yeah all right
further questions
represent almei
thank you
i'm trying to figure out when you're
looking at section two
collection
they're removing rental from everywhere
but we are also a hotel tax
so does that remove the hotel rentals
yeah it does leave the word occupant
yeah that's a mistake
but does this need to be rewritten if we
were going to pass this to
make sure that it's clear that we're
talking about rooms and males again
my apologies are represented army um so
you're referring to line
six onwards
section two out of collection
the question is no because certain
things that are rented are the cars
that's what has taken the renters out
so
so occupant would be the hotel yeah so
occupant is clearly in the definitions
the hotels right yes
so that's not being removed that's still
in the yeah that's my understanding yes
representative spellsbury
uh yes thank you mr chairman i do think
we should just check the statute to be
certain of ourselves but my recollection
of hb
was that
rental was the classification
specifically for the cars and rental
facilitator is what we were and what we
did in hp 15 is amend definitions
primarily
so
this probably suffices but we should be
sure right we should and what this does
is it just strikes out rental it keeps
it keeps the rental which is the cars so
we we should double check it i guess
yeah
good point
representative
mr chairman i believe it says on line 11
that the tax on meals and rooms is
included for the cost of meals and
lodging only
so that if we were talking about
occupants or whatever i believe i
believe it stated in here that that
stays
representative tucker
my understanding is listening to
enterprise
is that
we should eliminate the tax
because it's used by local people
the cars are being rented by locals
rather than out of states but i don't
see that this applies when i go to the
grocery store
and buy a prepared meal
i imagine most of the supermarkets that
sell prepared meals
that get charged
meals tax they're probably local people
too and we're not suggesting that
we should eliminate the tax on that
so i don't understand why it is that
out of state or in-state or local
is an argument one way or the other
it
it's just inconsistent i go to the
polish princess at lancaster
and buy an apple dumpling i'm
charged uh meals tax on that
most of the people who go to the bakery
they're local people so it isn't a
criteria here
to consider out of state in the state as
as an important factor i just don't
understand
the salience of the argument
represented
thank you mr chairman i think at the
time that we put in the car rental tax
which we were both involved in
accepting
in the poo-poo platter that did the
first education trust fund
that's what we were calling it
on
it was
it was put in at that time think we were
still thinking that most of the rooms
and mails tax was on
travelers visitors
tourists
uh
but that since then there have been
studies
on by plymouth state and i think the dra
data
on showing for instance the percentage
of the meals tax that comes from fast
food restaurants which usually isn't
tourists
that
indicated that we were
and also during the great recession
we
lost
a
fair amount of rooms and meals at first
i think but we lost
uh
a lot less than we were expecting and it
was because the local people were used
to eating out and were still trying to
eat out at the fast food places
so
i don't
think that
that we are with this taxing mostly
tourists we're taxing ourselves
uh
on in general
devon not as much in the rooms do you
have a breakdown
tourist versus local
devin roderick senior financial analyst
department revenue uh we do not break
down the meals and rooms tax based on
the
residency of the person renting or
reading out
okay
i would like to if you don't mind circle
back to the question about the
definition of renter yes
and occupant
within 783 under the definitions of the
meals and rentals tax
occupant is referring specifically to
those who rent a hotel
or
other dwelling
the term renter is referring
specifically to anyone who has provided
a vehicle under a rental agreement
okay
sorry what was the question
this is occupant which is hotels
or purchaser
purchaser meals
i'm looking at like line 13
or even online
occupant or purchaser
okay
further questions
thank you
sorry mr chair
representative lang sorry i do have one
more question with d.r.a robertson go
ahead sorry i just want to make sure
that the revenue
differential is around seven million
dollars is that we're talking about
annually if we're to repeal just this
portion of this tax
so the the
fiscal note based on fy 21
revenue
and assuming uh in you know
factoring in the eight and a half
percent rate that was passed last year
the total
impact would be 6.6 million
thank you you're welcome
all right next to the last one
is house house bill 1450
an act including agricultural resources
under the lantern community heritage
investment program
any questions or comments
i had a comment represent tucker yes
i received a note from
the new head of el chip
paula belmore
and she apparently had been watching the
streamed version
and heard me say that i would find out
about
land trusts
that
have agricultural interests
and
although the computer program was down
at that particular moment
she assured me that yes most land trusts
in new hampshire
do have
the ability to save agricultural lands
she did agree
that the definitions
of what is agricultural whether it would
include being a working
farm
all of those questions
may vary how they're answered land trust
to land trust and those are complicated
questions
but
she did feel that there were
other
groups
that were very interested and were
active in
uh agricultural resource uh preservation
so that was what i'd agreed to find out
and i did
represent elmi
thank you and i and i don't know which
others but i was told that they'd
contacted several other people on the
committee heard from the head of the
forest society
and the head of the nature conservancy
in new hampshire
yesterday they called me up i called the
forest society
guy back and discussed it with him
and they both
felt that they would be much more
comfortable with this bill being itled
and the reason was that they are
there have been
attempts in the past to remove the
l-chip funding or severely reduce it
and that they would rather be going on
with what they've got now and not risk
looking too greedy
essentially that's what they were saying
and they represented what
the
new hampshire society for the
[Music]
protection of new hampshire forests
and the nature conservancy new hampshire
branch
mr chair
representative lang representative
so i i happen to agree i think the
l-chip program is an extremely well
targeted program that's been extremely
uh successful and functional and in
protecting both our open lands as well
as our historical buildings and i think
expanding this puts it at risk
or increased risk and i would wholly
support an ital motion
represented tucker
i also heard from the nature conservancy
and
we discussed at some length
the
saving of three percent of the land
mass of new hampshire some years ago
on the predecessor l-chip and at that
time
in order to save the lands around
pittsburgh the old champion lands
a lot of money
was spent on one project and that had
the negative effect
of
shutting down
what became l-chip
for a year or two
and so
these are delicate balances in which the
public supports what's being done now
because of its great success
but that's always a jeopardy
if you change it too much
and you allowed any kind of greed to
appear on the on the horizon so i agree
with representative lang
further comment
questions
i see nothing else so
the work session on house bill
1450 is over
the last one
house bill 1478-fn-a
relative to the business profits tax
applicable to certain large low-wage
employees
questions or comments additional
information needed representation yeah
again i i'm not sure what additional
information needed uh
at best it's questionably constitutional
at worst it is definitely
unconstitutional um and and
again i i think this is an end around
that belongs over in the labor committee
it's an attempt to
to deal with uh
minimum wage laws um that belongs in the
wholly in the policy domain of labor so
i i highly recommend itl on this
mr chair um for other comments yeah
representative
i mean
we did pass this which i i don't think
we are but i hope not
i mean how
totally unworkable i mean how do you
we're going to have to dra is going to
have to keep track of companies with 100
or more people or less people and then
they have to keep track of the average
salary being 15
an hour
above or 15 an hour
below
it's an impossible task for dra you may
want to ask them to comment on that but
um that's my view i don't know how this
how can you how can this
even work
okay without adding a cast of thousands
in dra to make it work
just take
straw poll
all in favor of itl
i think that
ends it
i knew it was never going to fly but
again i thought the conversation needed
to be had and i have a friend that works
for
hhs and i called her
while we were
caucusing and said how often do you get
clients
that are looking for benefits that work
for these large companies and she said i
had two from walmart today said i'm on
the call still with one of them so it's
just something that
i think we should be enlightened about
that happens that we're subsidizing
people that these corporations could
very well take care of
so that's that's my piece thank you
any other comments
if not
representative
thank you i agree with that but i think
that there's a much clearer
there must be a clearer way to write a
bill that would bring that to attention
any further comments on 1478
and that clears up all of our
work session bills
the work session is over
here now the republicans that are here
we're going to have a
caucus
wednesday at 1 o'clock
everybody make that we need to get a
time
you have to be here
at one o'clock and we'll probably meet
downstairs in 104
i'll send you the room
yeah
sure
um
just as soon as when we can go down to
104 we can
wait till then
susan we're gonna have a caucus here
right now
then you can stay here and we'll go
downstairs
well we don't want to caucus right now
all right
one bill
what
15.65
caucus
and
we're working on a date where we can
uh
session dates confirmed
tuesday wednesday thursday one of those
videos
they think there's enough girls for two
days that's what you can
well the nine that we did here or a
couple of couple of yes's but they're
not going to be debated
there's only one no vote on a bill
my guess is that if it's thrown off
if it's a non-early bill
that we had
the
but they're pretty hard up they look for
customers
but that'll go like
that's a new story
out
school kids
um
is
and it's turning into a ranking
sometimes
you